and it's straight down past the hotel
registration
oh you know where it
have is be governor of all the people
[Music]
[Music]
hello good
good
[Music]
if i wanted an easy summer and a run for
re-election i need your help okay
we are being told that we have to choose
between whether working people will be
able to work whether it be an economy in
this state whether people be able to
afford to live here who have to work for
a living and whether or not we can have
the kind of environment
[Music]
on the grounds right now
jeff may be on the grounds we have one
person he had buttons in the ground he's
getting vision signatures great this is
a very scattered failure
guys
it gets a little tiring then we're
hanging in there how are you doing
people here you want another button
you're a socialist
yep we'll be voting for you thanks very
much how did you like one of these good
all right thank you buddy
where are you guys from
connecticut connecticut all right
sorry that's all right we're from where
from that one there you go
[Music]
just do the buttons
[Music]
[Music]
so you'd appreciate meeting lady wilder
who was a state representative from
orange county in the 30s
joy did a great deal too
you must have been one of the first
women there i think so yeah
do you remember
the woman from orange
she was the first woman legislator i
forgot her name right now
edna beer yes did you remember her oh
yeah
has anybody ever asked
governor madeline cunanan democrat of
vermont why are you running for
reelection
i'm running for reelection basically to
answer the question
whether vermont is moving in the right
direction since i've been governor for
about 18 months we've retired the
deficit we've improved funding for
education and we've enacted some very
strong environmental legislation i feel
that the job has been started that we
are going in the right direction and i'd
like to continue on that track how many
terms will it take you to complete the
agenda that you've set for yourself as
you know one one of the unique things
about vermont or the special things
about vermont is one of the few states
that just has a two-year term certainly
another term
to have four years to
carry forwards of these initiatives i
think is essential
lieutenant governor peter smith
republican running for governor why are
you running
well carl i think it would be safe to
say if i'd wanted an easy race i would
have run for re-election this summer
because really both of these people are
already legends in their own time but
for me
this isn't a race about legends it's a
race about the future of the state of
vermont and
you know what i think when many people
who are watching this show tonight think
about vermont they think of a white
farmhouse or a little town or a
dirt road or a gushing stream
and they think of this beautiful
pristine place but there's a family in
that farmhouse and that's a family that
is caught between high taxes and one of
the lowest incomes in the united states
of america amongst the highest taxes in
the united states of america and i'm
running for that family i'm running to
help them get out of a bond because
there's anxiety in that farmhouse and we
simply can't buy our way out of the
problems that we face we're going to
have to think our way out of those
problems and we're going to have to work
our way out of those problems
mayor bernard sanders independence mayor
of burlington why are you running for
governor
i'm running for governor
because i think it's time to stop the
tweedledee tweedledum politics of the
democratic and republican party in the
city of burlington we've done something
that has not been done in the united
states of america that is we've taken on
the democrats we've taped on the
republicans and we've beaten them we've
stood up for working people and poor
people we've said that there's something
immoral and wrong about a society in
which one half of one percent of the
population owns over one third of the
wealth where the rich dominate the
political spec scene
where working people are earning less
today in terms of real wages than they
earned
10 years ago i'm running for governor
because i think the issue of nuclear
power is an important issue and i think
finally we've got to decide whether or
not we want to continue nuclear power in
the state of vermont or we want to get
rid of it and i'm running for governor
because i think the state of vermont
should take a leadership role in this
nation in speaking out against the
absurd and virtually insane priorities
of the reagan administration which is
spending hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of billions of dollars on the
military and cutting back funding for
low-income people for working people for
the elderly and the poor we need
leadership in the state of vermont we're
not getting it today and that's why i'm
running for governor you've gotten a lot
of attention nationally as
america's the socialist mayor of
burlington america's socialist mayor are
you a socialist yes
why are you running as an independent
well the same reason that mrs cunanan
and mr smith are parts of the capitalist
economic system they're not running as
capitalists they're running as democrats
and republicans socialism to me means
democracy with a small d i am not
affiliated with a political party i am
an independent who happens to be a
socialist i am outraged about the system
that we're living in when you have
corporations and millionaires and
billionaires dominating the entire
society and as a socialist i want to see
a radical redistribution of wealth and
power in this country so the average
working person the average farmer the
average woman has a fair shake we're not
getting that socialism to me is a
philosophy but i'm not affiliated with
any particular socialist party
lieutenant governor peter smith
republican what are the major issues in
your campaign specifically outline them
for us
i think the point is that i disagree
fundamentally with both of my opponents
in terms of the tone in the direction of
state government
their course is for more spending more
government more employees and more
regulations
really let's think about the family in
the farmhouse again
you know that family and the other
working people in this state have just
lost a 16 to 17 million dollar cut in
their state personal income tax because
of the spending record of this
administration in the last two years
we've increased spending 63 million
dollars and that means government has
grown faster than the paycheck of the
average vermonter phone rates have gone
up three and a half million dollars more
than they needed to and that's not the
fault of the phone company it's the
fault of an administration the current
one that intervened at a time in the
process when they shouldn't have
my program property tax relief for the
people of this state but let's do it by
getting to the core of the problem state
mandates without state funding that
drive the property tax up have been
driving it up and more mandates in the
wings that will drive it up even further
limiting spending so that in fact
people's paycheck
increases faster than the rate of
spending in state government because
when it's the other way around the
working men and women of this state all
the people of this state the business
climate of this state all lose
those kinds of programs that's why i'm
running as governor cunanan done a poor
job of running the state for the last
two years lieutenant governor
i think rather than characterizing or
falling into the who struck john or in
this case who struck madeleine
let me tell you that the consequences
are really what matter i'm going to
leave it to other people to decide
whether or not she's done a good job or
a bad job we've got a thousand fewer
manufacturing jobs in this state than we
did a year ago we're at a five-year low
in the vermont industrial development
authority in terms of new applications
for grants and i got to tell you when
you look at the tax rate and you look at
the spending spending is up ten percent
a little less than that this year and
the revenue rates increasing by three
and a half percent there's trouble there
and i
the consequences are who's going to pay
and you know what this is a middle
income lower middle income state the
people are going to pay governor
madeleine cunning democrat running for
re-election what are the major issues
outline them for us as far as your
campaign is concerned
i'd like to just correct a few
statements that have been made in fact
the consequences are very important and
let me tell you about some of those
consequences first of all vermont's per
capita income grew the second highest of
any state in the nation in the last year
in the first quarter of 1986 we were the
third highest so vermont's income is
going up our unemployment rate 3.9
percent is the lowest it's been in years
since people have been calculating we've
added 8 800 new jobs in the last year
every single statistic says that this
state is on a roll that this state is
doing very well doesn't mean it's
perfect for everybody but it does mean
we're moving in the right direction we
retire the deficit i'm the only governor
in this country that started out with
the highest deficit of any state nine
percent of our general fund that's what
i inherited from a republican
administration today we have an 8.9
million dollar surplus those are results
these two gentlemen can talk about what
they would do he can talk about a
theoretical family in a farmhouse we all
love that family in the farmhouse but
what we we done what we have done is
increase their earning power and that is
important for the future vermonters yes
we've got more to do we are still below
the national average in per capita
income but the important point is we are
moving fast and we've made the right
investments in that spending in
education to improve the quality of life
and the quality of jobs that people can
have in the state that's an issue good
evening c-span is live from montpelier
vermont we're here in the second floor
of the state capitol building the
governor's reception room we've been
here camped out for about four days
trying to give you around the country or
in vermont a look at politics in this
state what are some of the major issues
and the candidates this evening we're
going to be looking specifically at the
race for governor we have with us three
of the major candidates for governor to
my left already been introduced governor
madeline cunanan democrat running for
reelection
next to her lieutenant governor peter
smith republican candidate and finally
mayor bernard sanders mayor of
burlington running as an independent in
just a few moments we're going to be
opening up the phone lines and we're
going to try to take as many calls as we
possibly can each of the candidates will
have one chance to respond to each of
your questions but as if you're a
regular c-span viewer you know we put a
heavy emphasis on involving you so if
you have a question or a comment we'd
like to hear from you we'd like to get
your opinion or hear your questions
there but there will be one special line
for those of you living within the state
of vermont and those of you watching
around the country will be able to use
that second line and we'll start taking
phone calls in just a few moments this
country has just seen a
major debate over the issue of tax
reform and we're very likely about to
see it passed by congress the other day
in the newspaper mayor sanders you said
that you have some new idea of a tax
system for this state specifically you
had made it clear in the article lisa
that i read that you were about two
weeks away from announcing that can you
tell us anything about that if you were
elected how would you change attacks
governor cunanan talks about taxes from
a statewide point of view from here in
montpelier but what she's missing is a
very important point is that in the last
year in the state of vermont property
taxes have zoomed up what we have today
in the state of vermont is a property
tax crisis property taxes went up by 28
million dollars the state of vermont
this state is far more dependent upon
the property tax than almost any other
state in the union we are not adequately
funding education we're far below what
we should be funding education compared
to the national average what we need
right now in the state of vermont is
major tax reform and the tax reform can
and must be brought about by decoupling
vermont's personal and corporate income
tax from the federal income tax system
governor cunanan correctly talks about
the deficit that existed in the state of
vermont and that's right we have lost
several hundred million dollars in
revenue to the state of vermont which
has caused our deficit because the
legislature and the governors have not
had the courage to say let's make tax
policy here in the state of vermont
let's not give tax breaks to the wealthy
and the corporations that they get on
the federal level and have that
translated into tax breaks for the rich
and the corporations here in the state
of vermont and we've lost in the last
five years several hundred million
dollars in revenue and lo and behold
we've had a deficit to the best of my
knowledge neither one of my opponents
has the guts to say let's decouple let's
ask the wealthy people in this state the
corporations to start paying their fair
share let's take the burden of taxation
off of the homeowner or for the farmer
through increased property taxes
governor cunanan
taxes major issue and should we see a
major change in vermont well i think
mayor sanders speech would have been
fine before the federal tax law was
in a committee of conference not quite
fast yet but actually vermonters are
going to benefit enormously more than
people from the rest of the country
because of our income distribution we
have more
vermonters at the middle and lower
income scale and fewer at the very top
we're going to get an average of a 10
percent tax cut for vermonters and about
20 percent of our taxpayers will be
taken off the tax rolls entirely
for the short term that is a very good
thing that we are coupled to the federal
income tax for the long term i would
like to see what exactly the impact is
on middle-income vermont taxpayers
lieutenant governor smith any changes in
taxes if you were elected well i think
the interesting thing is that in this
particular case we don't know what the
long term is and i got to tell you i'm
opposed to decoupling b flat the
governor says that income growth has
gone up seven percent and that's third
in the country but vermont started at 46
of 47th and we all know that a
percentage growth on a low base can be
disproportionate now look what happened
is that when we retired the deficit and
i was here when we put that plan
together there was another part to that
plan and it was to limit spending to six
percent so that in case we raised more
money than we anticipated it wouldn't go
into an inflated budget but we didn't do
that and we went out at nine percent and
nine percent and what has happened now
is that the working people of this state
because that's who the people in vermont
are ten thousand to twenty five thousand
dollars a year that's who they are
they've lost the benefit of the
pass-through that the piggyback would
have given them and they've lost it
because we didn't follow the whole
deficit reduction plan now i'll tell you
i think it's going to be a major issue
in this campaign and my answer to taxes
is to put a lid on spending and get more
and get better to think our way work our
way out of the problems we've got and
reform our systems from the inside out
from the bottom up rather than just
spending more money and adding on we're
going to go to the phones each of you
had a chance to talk about taxes on
taxes we're gonna go we're gonna go to
the phones i'm sure there will be more
questions on taxes since it affects
absolutely everybody first call is uh
from burlington want to remind you that
if you live in vermont one special
number for you and the other number for
those of you watching around the country
if you have a question or comment please
feel free to give us a call let's take
the first call of the hour from
burlington you're on the air go ahead
please
hello uh like everybody in the united
states i was aghast at what happened in
chernobyl
with the nuclear disaster
disaster uh i'd like to ask the three
candidates we have in vermont a nuclear
facility vermont yankee
which has a containment structure almost
exactly like the one in chernobyl
what do you propose to do about vermont
yankee and the possibility of of uh
catastrophe there and specifically how
long do you think it should continue to
operate right now it's proposed to
operate for another 20 years do you
favor shutting it down and how long do
you propose to let it operate okay
burlington thanks for the call mayor
bernard sanders why don't you start okay
that's a very very important question
and i think you know there are honest
people on both sides of the issue and
it's a complicated issue i think
ultimately one has to make a decision
and the decision is whether one has
enough confidence in nuclear power to
say that we want nuclear power
in vernon to continue for another 20
years whether we say it just ain't worth
the risk
um i'm not proposing or telling anybody
that the yankee nuclear power plant is
going to blow up tomorrow it's not
but i think ultimately after a lot of
thinking and i have to say that i have
not been one of the great anti-nuclear
activists in the state of vermont but i
think after a lot of thinking and i
think the chernobyl incident made me
think a little bit more about it that i
think it is time to say loudly and
clearly let's shut down yankee it is not
worth the risk but let's not shut it
down tomorrow because if you shut it
down tomorrow electric rates would go up
we in the state of vermont border on
canada canada has an enormous surplus of
hydroelectric power what i believe we
should be announcing very loudly and
very clearly is let's close down that
nuclear power plant as quickly as we can
i think we can close it down in three
years i think immediately you begin
negotiating with the provinces of quebec
for cheap hydro power i think in the
long run you can get that power as
inexpensively as the nuclear power is
available to us today and i think in the
long run we're going to sleep a lot more
safely at night without that nuclear
power lieutenant governor peter smith
if you look at where the problem came
from after chernobyl and after the
yankee shutdown for retooling this
summer there was a real scare here and
it was because a man by the name of
denton from the nuclear regulatory
commission was quoted by some state
officials as saying that there was
something like a 90 percent chance that
vermont yankee uh
would totally demolish in the case of a
total meltdown
so what we now and people were anxious
and i was anxious what we now know is
that in fact professor rasmussen from
mit nuclear physicist who wrote the
report that mr denton
was quoting has come back and said
his uh his assessment of that report was
very pessimistic that in fact the
vermont yankee study which was just
finished which shows
something like a seven percent
chance of total of total failure in the
case of a meltdown is far far more
accurate what i think we've got to
understand here is that none of us are
going to take a back seat when it talk
when we talk about public safety that's
really not the issue the issue as far as
i can tell is whether or not we want 50
state
regulatory agencies supplementing the
nrc or whether we want to speak through
the national governors
wherever we can through the congress to
have the nrc have a higher
and more firm and more explicit standard
for safety so that we don't have states
which become havens for un or less safe
plants and other states which pay for
power from other sources i think yankee
ought to stay open i think we ought to
continue to close it to retool it and i
think the governor of this state ought
to get his or her hands on this problem
not rely on a new division or more
bureaucrats in order to solve it
duplicating expenses but in fact get in
jawbone and force the nrc and vermont
yankee to come to the table governor
cunanan
i think the real question is is the
vermont nuclear power plant safe
and as governor i have taken very
specific steps to make certain that it
is
when our plant was down for nine months
for repairs
and the interim chernobyl happened
raised a lot of legitimate anxiety about
chernobyl and also the study came out
that said plants of the type of
vermont yankee that had a mark one
containment system did have a 90 percent
chance of the failure of that
containment system if there was a
nuclear meltdown needless to say that
did cause a great deal of
anxiety and frankly justifiable i think
the world of nuclear power is different
as a result of chernobyl but it also is
different in the sense that we have to
make rational decisions based on the
best information that we have it so
happens that vermont has one third of
its power from the vermont yankee
nuclear power plant if i have evidence
that that plant is unsafe i would be the
first person to call for the shutdown of
that plant what i am seeking and what we
are in the process of obtaining is
objective information as to how we can
increase the level of safety i've been a
governor who's been very outspoken on
nuclear power i've asked for a
resolution which was passed at the
national governor's conference to allow
states in certain defined instances to
have higher safety standards
than the nuclear regulatory commission
if our containment system is different
than others in the country we should be
able to have tougher standards than
other states the same time before i call
for the shutdown of that plan i want to
make certain that we have
competitively priced power and that
there is a genuine
question of safety in the meantime i'm
putting the heat on the nuclear
regulatory commission and on vermont
yankee to
increase the level of safety by
strengthening that containment system
that is a reasonable rational approach i
don't think you have to fall into an
anti-nuke or a pro-new position what
we're looking for is safe affordable
power for the people of the state we're
known in minnesota you're our next
caller go ahead please
i should like to ask the governor what
the
situation is with regard to the asset
rain situation and thank you all hang up
now all right thanks for the call
governor cunhan acid rain well i'm very
glad to hear that that people from
minnesota are concerned about acid rain
as we are it's probably one of the major
environmental issues for us in the state
of vermont and we with other
northeastern states and with canada have
jointly put a tremendous amount of
pressure uh on the congress and on the
president on the epa to have some tough
standards in place in the meantime in
the state of vermont we're doing what we
can as well we have had a visibility
study that we believe our visibility
at our higher elevations is caused by
emissions from the midwestern states and
to meet epa's own standards of what our
visibility should be
we have requested that the epa reduce
the emissions from those western states
we hope that they will pay attention to
that request they are now
seriously considering that we're using
every tool available through our
congressional delegation through our own
studies to have an impact but basically
it's a question
that is a tug of war in the congress and
within the environmental protection
agency lieutenant governor peter smith
what would you do if elected
i think that acid rain is a subject in
which the three of us are going to agree
and in fact the previous governor agreed
also and much of the work that the
governor has just talked about and the
attitude that she has carried forward is
one that was inherited from the previous
administration in the essence i don't
think the congress is going to solve
this problem because it's a deep
political problem we have senators from
ohio indiana west virginia pennsylvania
where thousands of jobs depend on the
industry which creates the coal which
goes into those which goes into those
factories those plants i think the
person in this state who deserves
commendation and where the real progress
is going to be made beyond the job
owning and all of the things that we
would do and i would do them too is the
attorney general jeffrey amistori who in
fact has joined other northeastern
attorney generals to take the acid rain
case to court that in the end maybe
unfortunately but realistically is where
this problem is going to be solved and
it's going to be solved on a legal basis
i think long before the politicians can
reach common cause with it mayor sanders
in the state of vermont today thousands
of acres of our best farmland is being
destroyed by acid rain
the president of the united states and
the democrats and republicans in
congress have a strange set of
priorities they're willing to
appropriate hundreds of millions of
dollars to overthrow the government of
nicaragua to spend or propose a hunt a
trillion dollars for the star wars
program 300 billion dollars for the
military every year but somehow or
another the leadership in washington
just can't find the money to solve the
problem of acid rain without laying off
thousands of workers in the midwest what
this issue of acid rain is about it is
symptomatic of the priorities that exist
in washington and one of the reasons
that i am running for governor acid rain
is one of many is that in this country
you've got to have leadership which
challenges those absurd irrational
priorities the environment is precious
all of us agree on that there's no
question about that what we need now is
leadership all over this country to say
to mr reagan the democrats and the
republicans in congress hey stop
spending your hundreds of billions on
the military and overthrowing the
government of nicaragua let's deal with
the environment let's not cut back on
environmental protection and let's solve
the problem of acid rain immediately
we're live from montpelier vermont we're
here to take a look at vermont politics
joining us now three of the major
candidates for governor in the state if
you have a question or comment we'd like
to hear from you and you can use those
numbers which will appear periodically
at the bottom of your screen rutland
vermont you're next go ahead please
uh yes uh here in rutland we are
presently
witnessing the construction of a waste
to energy plant and recently there was a
report that was put out by professor
brooks from vermont law school and
others
that reported on the projected pollution
problems that would be associated with
the vicon project and i was wondering if
the candidates could tell me whether
they agree with this report and what
their position is on the vicon project
governor cunanan wants to start with
that
well the vicon project which is a waste
energy plant as the questioner described
has been very thoroughly reviewed in
fact my administration reopened the
whole process to make doubly certain
that this plant will
comply with the very strictest of air
quality standards i have not had an
opportunity to analyze this law
professor's report but i'm confident
that when an air quality permit
is issued for this plant it will be
under circumstances that do assure
safety i think we are in a period where
we have to
recognize that any form of the disposal
of trash or waste is going to have some
consequences you can't have something
that you can't see you can't hear you
can't smell and that just dissipates
into another planet but we do have a
responsibility to make certain that
there are no ill health effects and i'm
confident that the stringency of this
permit process will guarantee that
lieutenant governor smith
i haven't seen the report either and i'm
hoping when the governor gets done
looking at it she'll send send us a copy
we're going to try to lay our hands on
it too i think there's no doubt that
there are serious serious questions
about trash to energy
disposal
we just simply have to wait and see and
we have to be as careful as we can be
but i'll tell you if it comes down that
we're not going to build that plant
because people's safety is in danger
then we're not going to build it i have
taken the step and i'm the only
candidate here that has taken the step
of really biting the bullet on solid
waste and recycling and saying we need a
15-year plan we need to look at how we
put our current landfills to bed zip
them up if you will that costs money and
right now the state's playing the role
of a policeman not the role of a partner
with our local communities and we got to
see this as a common problem
we've got to figure out how to
capitalize pay for
together regional state-of-the-art
landfills and if we can solve this
problem on trash to energy one or more
of those but the fact is the longer we
wait
the worse the solid waste problem gets
in this state and it is a bomb that is
ticking and it isn't going to go away
it's a crisis already and it's going to
be worse in five years recycling i think
we can turn that into an economic
activity and i think we ought to do it
pretty quickly because people up here
need jobs and need a good business mayor
sanders
well i suppose i'm the only one up here
who has had the privilege or lack of
privilege of actually vetoing a resource
recovery plan when i became mayor of the
city of burlington there was a plan
established by my predecessor to build a
resource recovery plant right in the the
center of the city of burlington and i
vetoed it
for economic reasons as well as
environmental reasons
what you're dealing with is a very
complicated difficult problem
and i don't know the answer there are
very
serious sober brilliant people such as
barry commodore who simply don't trust
what the industry is saying
don't believe the figures that are being
released feel the dioxins that are being
emitted into the air that are coming
down to the earth that are being eaten
by cows that could get into the food
chain
are really insurmountable problems i
honestly don't know the answer i am
nervous about it here in the city of
burlington we have established for
example a recycling program clearly one
of the things that we want to do to do
is to get as much of the trash out of
the system as possible uh we are we are
improving our landfill right now i think
it's probably as good as any in the
state of vermont to answer your question
is i don't know the answer i am very
very scared very nervous about these uh
resource to recovery plants and i i just
don't have enough information to say
whether we go with them or not clearly
if we do go with them the requirements
have got to be very very stringent in
point the fact there are people who say
let's not go with them at all and my
mind is open uh as to what the final
results will be i just don't know at
this point phone lines are open if you
have a question or comment please feel
free to join our discussion next call is
from saint croix in the virgin islands
go ahead please
all right good evening
my crushing concern is hazardous waste
and maybe this is something that
shouldn't be discussed on national tv
but there are several hazardous waste
sites in vermont
with perhaps the most famous or the most
infamous one being williamstown vermont
my question
to mayor sanders lieutenant governor
smith
is
what they would do to ensure that
williamstown is properly cleaned up
after three years we still don't have
the people williamstown still don't have
a new water supply what they would do to
ensure that is built in a speedy cleanup
and my question to the governor is
why after talking such a good
environmental
game during the campaign
did she turn her back onto the people of
williamstown
refusing to come to
meetings in williamstown not returning
phone calls or office not returning
phone calls and why after two years
there isn't a new water supply uh in
williamstown okay before you go where
are you calling from caller
i'm a displaced williamstown person i
now live in the virgin islands and how
are you watching us you have your own
satellite dish
no cable cable system all right thanks
for the call we appreciate it mayor
sanders why don't you start
in a state with as rural a population as
ours
the state government itself has got to
play an enormously active role in the
area of environmental protection
most of the communities the city of
burlington is far and away the largest
city in the state and we don't have the
resources to deal effectively with the
exploding new technologies and analyzing
the problems the state itself has got to
play a leadership role in point of fact
the state of vermont sued the
environmental conservation agency in
truth we lost the suit but we sued them
because in our view the statutes of the
state of vermont are very clear about
the need for the environmental
conservation agency to take the
leadership role to solve these problems
i have talked to some of the people in
williamstown i've talked to people
around the state of vermont and i think
what they are saying and what the caller
is saying is right that the state has
not been as vigorous as it should be it
is good to be concerned everybody is
concerned it is good to hold press
conferences but in point of fact it
takes money
and it takes courage to go out there and
solve the problems i don't think the
state has been doing that lieutenant
governor
once again i think the position of the
state over the last three three years on
the williamstown situation specifically
the leadership role fell to the attorney
general of the state of vermont they
brought a suit it was a difficult suit
the fact of the matter is the state won
the suit the company has made redress
and it's a difficult problem it's going
to take time to clean it up
i can't speak for what the involvement
of the governor has or hasn't been
obviously that's up to her and that was
your different question to her but when
these problems happen
to me the only thing you can do as
difficult as they are is go after the
people determine whose fault it is go
after them make them pay and fix the
problem and i think it's taken time and
it's been enormously difficult for the
people of that town and i understand
that but in fact that has been happening
and i think
we ought to confuse the difficulty of
the problem
with the solution as
slow as it may have seemed as long as it
may be taken with the certainty that the
problem is going to be solved governor
cunanan
i'm afraid the caller has been out of
touch with what is happening at
williamstown because in fact
williamstown is a prime example of the
aggressive
steps that this administration has taken
in return in terms of cleanup the first
decision that i had to make the day
after i was sworn in as governor was
whether to accept a previously
negotiated agreement with the previous
attorney general and administration on
williamstown i rejected it because it
was not good enough it did not have the
kind of redress not did not address the
basic problems of the people of
williamstown we worked i'd say almost
day and night on having a new
arrangement with williamstown and i
would say almost everybody in
williamstown is very grateful that we
did that and today the people of
williamstown have a much better deal
they have much better redress they will
have exactly what they need for safe
school and for a safe drinking water
system i'm very proud of what we did
we worked cooperatively with the
attorney general but it was this
administration and all the people in it
that took the lead and i'm very proud of
that we held hearing after hearing in
williamstown we gave much opportunity
for public input and i'm afraid the
caller is misinformed because
williamstown is an example of what a
tough administration can do to turn
around a situation that was quite
dangerous for the people there
for the last four days we've been live
from the governor's reception room in
the uh vermont state capitol and we'd
like to thank all the people that have
allowed us to do this and cooperate with
us some of those include the
sergeant-at-arms reid payne and teresa
randall the state house we appreciate
their cooperation and many of the other
people that have worked with us and
allowing us to do this we appreciate it
it's a very old historic building and if
you're ever in montpelier you have a
chance come here and take a tour because
you'll probably learn an awful lot about
u.s history not to mention vermont
history next call middlebury vermont
you're on the air go ahead please
hello my question has to do with
low-income people
and
i would like to ask each one of the
candidates what it is from their
campaign that they are offering
low-income people
and i would like to
specifically talk about something other
than uh
tax relief
lieutenant governor why don't we start
with you on that one let me give you one
specific example this state is about to
receive in the neighborhood of sometimes
between seven and ten million dollars
one from a suit
with major
law firms i mean oil oil companies i'm
sorry now the question is what do we do
with that money my proposal has been
that we put that money into a revolving
trust fund invested at the state level
it would take legislation to do this so
that low-income people people who need
housing rehabbed or developed can do
that out of a perpetual fund living off
the income of this
of this housing trust fund
so what we could do is set people in a
position where they could strengthen the
houses they have make them more energy
efficient and help them with new housing
it's a proposal we've talked about with
low-income representatives we have an
opportunity to do something to endow a
real problem that low-income people in
the state of vermont face as well as
low-income people all over this country
it's a once really in a lifetime
opportunity all of the other proposals
that i've seen are in fact to spend this
seven to ten million dollars to spend it
in the next two to three to four years
and then it'll be gone forever i don't
think we ought to spend it i think we
ought to invest it so that down the road
we can continue to have a housing policy
for poor people low-income people in the
state of vermont governor madeleine
cunanan i just add that every state is
getting its share of that oil over
charge money and it has very
definite federal stipulations so this
may be a well-intentioned proposal but
we have to be able to
tailor it to what the federal demands
are on this whether we like it or not
i am
initiating and it's already started i'm
going to invest a great deal of time and
energy in the future in a program called
reach-up which basically helps
low-income people get jobs and enter the
labor force this reach-up program will
particularly focus on single parents who
need the kind of assistance to get into
the labor force job training child care
transportation and to bridge the gap
between welfare and work our goal is to
get a thousand people off of welfare in
this coming year i think we're going to
do it i'm very excited about it the best
program we can provide for low-income
people is a decent job which allows
people to support themselves and
wherever possible that's the goal of
this administration we're not possible
we have a responsibility to maintain
people so that they can have
security and that is also a goal of ours
mayor bernard sanders i strongly
disagree with both of my opponents on
the issue of what we should be doing for
low-income people and i'm very proud of
the record that we've established in the
city of burlington where we've developed
a wide range of programs to benefit
low-income people without the kind of
resources available here at the state of
vermont we started at the daycare center
uh one of the nicest day care centers in
the state of vermont we started
emergency shelters so the people in the
city of burlington no longer have to
sleep on the street we've started some
of the most exciting housing programs in
the state of vermont we started a
shelter for battered women uh in a whole
host of programs but i think let's let's
step back for a moment and look at the
overall problem what's going on in this
country today and in this state today is
that the rich in fact are getting richer
and working people and poor people are
in worse shape than they've ever been
their standard of living is radically
declining what you need in the state of
vermont is tax reform tax reform which
will free up minimum 50 million dollars
which will provide adequately for social
services in the state of vermont it is
not acceptable to me that we have a
crisis in daycare for example so that
working mothers and we're not just
talking about the reach up program which
is nothing more than a continuation of
the wind program we need massive we need
to spend a minimum of a million and a
half dollars building day care centers
around the state of vermont so the women
have the opportunity to go out to work
we're talking about raising the minimum
wage neither of my opponents are
supporting the suggestions that i made
that have elected governor raise the
minimum wage to four bucks an hour
because people can't afford to live on
345 an hour serious tax reform property
tax reform which takes the burden of
taxation off the lower moderate income
people and places on those people and
institutions who can afford to pay the
most important issue though when you
deal with low-income people is this fact
and i'm going to make this fact slowly
because i want it to seep in
every night we watch television we look
at south africa isn't that a tragedy
there the blacks in south africa they
can't vote they don't have political
rights the fact of the matter is that in
the state of vermont the overwhelming
majority of poor and working people have
given up on the political process they
don't vote they don't believe in the
democratic party they don't believe in
the republican party during this
campaign i believe strongly i am the
only candidate who's gone out to the
trailer box the low income housing
projects and i'm knocking on the door
you know what people say why should i
bother to vote it doesn't make a damn
bit of difference the rich people
control what's going on i do not believe
in tinkering with the system what we
have done in burlington has taken on our
ruling class we've taken on the people
who've owned the city historically we've
made many changes that's what has got to
happen in the state of vermont we need a
governor who's going to stand up for low
income and working people and make the
right fight not cut back not cut back on
programs that are desperately needed
before we go to the next call very
quickly lieutenant governor would you
favor raising the minimum wage in
vermont
no i wouldn't and i got to tell you that
in fact in responding to the mayor
really what you've just said
is nonsense i have campaigned in trailer
parks and i've campaigned in low-income
housing projects and i've campaigned in
the the old north end of burlington and
i've talked to people that i've known
all my life and i'm just talking to
different people than you are mayor i
have to tell you when we're talking
about what we're going to do for poor
people we have to talk about the
investment we already make because i've
taken a very clear stand we are not
going to buy our way out of the problems
that we're into we need to look at human
service delivery look at what we've
learned in the last 20 years ask the
people who deliver in human services at
the field level and reform that system
from the bottom up so that we get more
efficiency whole person treatment and
that's going to take leadership and i'm
going to be a governor raising the
minimum wage
i would not raise the minimum wage no
governor cunanan would you oppose where
would you favor raising the minimum wage
right now we're in the process of
raising the minimum wage the legislature
passed a law raising at 10 cents each
year
after the third year i would consider
raising it again i think it's very
difficult to live on the minimum wage
but we also have to have decent paying
jobs you can't live on four dollars you
can't raise a family on four dollars in
fact they're very few four dollar an
hour jobs in the state of vermont today
we have to have decent paying jobs and
that's what is the goal of my
administration san diego california
patiently waiting 3000 miles away go
ahead please
i don't want to break the continuity too
much but she did mention last on minimum
wage
and today with the breakdown of families
it's more important for
young people to be able to support
themselves outside of the home
my question is directed more towards
what you were talking about earlier
about energy
um
do are this directed to all of you um do
you feel that we can live without an
energy source like the sun
the obvious answer is no we should be
directing our our energies to harvesting
that and protecting that future
source of energy we don't
we're not the country isn't running on
solar energy but uh out here in
california we try to you know what i
mean
it's really important for us to kind of
realize that that is definitely in the
future so your question is about how
much solar power how much the state of
vermont is relying upon solar power
is that the question caller i think we
get it thank you very much we appreciate
it mayor sanders why don't you start
obviously he wasn't here this summer we
didn't have very much sun but uh
i think he raises
a very good question and that question
again gets back to the issue of nuclear
power one of the tragedies
of this period in history is that the
corporations who control the energy
production in this country have made a
decision to spend
probably hundreds of billions of dollars
in research and development of nuclear
power i think most sane people
understand that if a fraction of that
money was spent in other types of energy
development today the united states of
america would be able to have less
expensive energy and a lot safer energy
i think clearly here in the state of
vermont we've got to explore all the
alternatives that we can we've got to be
far more vigorous in terms of
weatherization and energy conservation
as well senate governor
well i've already talked about
weatherization and conservation and how
to do that for the people who can at
least afford to do it for themselves the
fact is if you look at what vermonters
rely on for their energy you have the
whole mix you have low head hydro you
have solar you you have oil you have
coal you have wood and what we've
discovered
is that for virtually every one of them
there's a downside as well as an upside
and i think what we're after is a mix
it's a mix and i think the state with
that mix does a couple of things one it
preserves itself and it pro and it
stabilizes itself against a major change
in any one of those sources and two it
keeps prices down for people governor
i think uh vermonters are a good
conservationist by virtue of necessity
because one of the nice things about
this program is you can suddenly see the
world from california's eyes at
vermont's eyes and obviously we have
somewhat less solar energy than you do
in california though surprisingly during
the energy crunch we did do things like
have solar heated calf barns and below
zero temperature
and we're going to continue with those
kinds of innovations but
conservation has to be part of our mix
because we're so dependent on energy for
survival in this part of the country and
that's going to be our strategy for the
future as it has been in hard times the
challenge will be to continue doing that
while the price of oil for the period
that we're in right now is low
c-span's campaign 86 is spending an hour
and a half this evening looking at
politics in vermont this evening
specifically the race for governor in
the state of vermont one question that
comes to my mind is in running for the
office of governor what does it pay what
does one receive for being governor of
vermont governor keenan
i think i got a raise in the last
legislative session and it's uh i think
sixty two thousand five hundred dollars
what are the benefits how does that rate
you were at the national governor's
association meeting down in hilton head
what goes along with that some of the
benefits of being governor is there a
mansion for the governor vermont is a
frugal and
modest state in every sense and there is
no mansion there are no what you call
perks like helicopters and airplanes uh
i have a driver and live in my own house
and i kind of like it that way what does
the office of lieutenant governor
receive in the state of vermont
i think this year i received 25 000 a
year and for all the perks that the
governor doesn't have i have fewer but i
think in fact what uh draws us uh to
public service and one of the things uh
the frankly i'm concerned about
losing that we're losing in this state
but i think what draws most people to
public service in this state is the
ideal of serving it is not an area in
which you're going to make a lot of
money the legislature is still a citizen
legislature where people from all walks
of life come together to make law
for not a lot of money and that's
something i think we're proud of and
we're going to fight to defend you have
a job outside of being lieutenant
governor no i do not
what does the office of mayor in
burlington vermont pay well we haven't
gotten many raises lately but i think
we're up to about 43 000 a year
but that includes having to answer the
calls about the dogs that are barking
late at night getting the snow off the
street in the middle of the night so
it's
probably earned that money phone lines
are open if you have a question or
comment please feel free to join our
discussion burlington you're on go ahead
please
uh
mayor sanders
why don't the governor and lieutenant
governor work for the minimum wage
the governor and lieutenant governor are
social canalis for personal gain i know
them both
and they do not represent the uh
the powerless people of berman they
represent big interest
take it from me i know
corruption is vermont's number one
problem bernard and you know it you're
the mayor
that's what you got to bring up wait a
minute that's what you got to bring up
if you're pure you'll bring it up and
you'll win the governorship of vermont
burlington thanks for the commerce well
i don't know how pure i am but i i don't
accept the basis that that gentleman was
talking about certainly i think in fact
in the state of vermont
one of the things that all of us are
very proud of is that by and large with
occasional exceptions but by and large
public servants and public servants in
the state work very very hard do not in
general get paid a whole lot of money
and are honest decent people no one has
ever suggested i think in this campaign
anything to the country i strongly
disagree with governor kew and
lieutenant governor smith regarding
their desire not to raise the minimum
wage i mean i think the 345 is not a
livable wage four bucks an hour today 4
20 next year 440 is the beginning of
starting to pay our workers a living
wage but i don't believe that the fact
that the governor and lieutenant
governor are opposed to that indicates
that they're corrupt i think there's a
there's a difference of opinion here
governor cunanan any response from the
constituent in birmingham just correct
i'm not opposed to raising the minimum
wage we are raising it and i said i
would i said i would after that raise
goes through uh support an additional
raise but i am
kind of disturbed by that question
because it really is not typical of the
view of politics in vermont we if
anything we do have a very honest and
accountable system and i notice the
mayor doesn't work for the minimum wage
either but that's not the question the
real question is that politics is real
politics is honest and i know of
absolutely no
no smidgen of corruption in the state
i'm very proud of that senate governor
well i would i would just say that
honestly i don't think the
question which wasn't a question
merits a response i would say that the
real problem and
one of the reasons that i got into this
race is that when you talk to working
people and their issue isn't the minimum
wage when you talk to working people who
live in the countryside or the state of
vermont they're worried about whether or
not they're going to be able to afford
to continue to live there what we need
to do is create a diverse and a rugged
economy agriculture the travel industry
manufacturing service so that people can
choose and that's what drives and
strengthens the wage structure and
drives wages up is economic competition
not a false bottom and that's where we
ought to put our energy into better
education into better economic
development so that people have choices
that's where power comes from choices
manhattan new york go ahead please yes
my name is blake morris and i'm a
resident town of bradford vermont i'm
calling to address the governor and
lieutenant governor and mr sanders in
regards to
the situation of liability insurance in
vermont i'm a small business owner in
bradford and commercial insurance is the
commercial viability insurance has gone
sky high especially in the area of
liquor liability insurance where there's
only one underwriter in the state i'd
like to know if they have any plans to
address this as the governor next year
governor
thank you well vermont is not a
governor thank you well vermont is not
immune from the problems that have been
facing other states but i think you have
to be very careful as you try to uh
limit liability because from the
problems that have been facing other
states but i think you have to be very
careful as you try to limit liability
because that does not necessarily result
in availability of cheaper insurance and
we really do have a responsibility here
too to those people who are that does
not necessarily result in availability
of cheaper insurance and we really do
have a responsibility here too to those
people who are the victims of
people driving under the influence of
alcohol
through our insurance commissioner we
are carefully reviewing this situation
with the victims of
people driving under the influence of
alcohol
through our insurance commissioner we
are carefully reviewing this situation
we may have some recommendations for the
next legislative session but simply
putting a cap on liability does not
automatically assure available may have
some recommendations
for the next legislative session but
simply putting a cap on liability does
not automatically assure availability we
are providing assistance uh to
uh purchases of insurance to help them
shop around to get affordable insurance
we will continue to literally we are
providing assistance uh to
uh purchases of insurance to help them
shop around to get affordable insurance
we will continue to do that and we are
exploring legislation for the next
session mayor sanders
it's a real the gentleman who called hit
the nail on the head it is a very
serious problem and do that and we are
exploring legislation for the next
session mayor sanders
it's a real the gentleman who called hit
the nail on the head it is a very
serious problem and during the course of
this campaign we're going to try to deal
with it in a definitive way what the
problem is cities and towns throughout
the state including the city of burling
i've seen rapid increases in our
liability during the course of this
campaign we're going to try to deal with
it in a definitive way what the problem
is is cities and towns throughout the
state including the city of berlin i've
seen rapid increases in our liability
insurance which has to be passed on back
to the taxpayers taxi cab owners have
seen increases bars have seen increases
small business people have seen
increases fares the insurance which has
to be passed on back to the taxpayers
taxi cab owners have seen increases bars
have seen increases small business
people have seen increases fares the
wonderful events that have gone on for
years and years i was at a fair in
milton and they're not sure that they're
going to be able to carry it on next
year because of the difficulties of
liability insurance i think there are a
couple of issues that you have wonderful
events that have gone on for years and
years i was at a fair in milton and
they're not sure that they're going to
be able to carry it on next year because
of the difficulties of liability
insurance i think there are a couple of
issues that you have to tackle here i
think one of them is to perhaps take a
very good look at the monopolies in the
insurance industry and seeing the
reasons why it is becoming very very
difficult faculty i think one of them is
to perhaps take a very good look at the
monopolies in the insurance industry and
seeing the reasons why it is becoming
very very difficult for people and for
institutions to get affordable insurance
and second of all to see about the
possibility of the state playing an
increasing role in providing insurance
actually uh for people and for
institutions to get affordable insurance
and second of all to see about the
possibility of the state playing an
increasing role in providing insurance
actually to communities and institutions
that need it
lieutenant governor smith i think it
would come as no surprise to you that i
disagree with both my opponents first of
all let's the communities and
institutions that need it
lieutenant governor smith
i think it would come as no surprise to
you that i disagree with both my
opponents first of all let's look at
what we could have done
last year because the gentleman spoke
about liquor liability and we had a very
good piece of liquor liability to look
at what we could have done
last year because the gentleman spoke
about liquor liability and we had a very
good piece of liquor liability capping
legislation dram shop legislation and it
was lost in the legislature in the
closing days and one of the reasons it
was lost because of the failure of the
governor capping legislation dram shop
legislation and it was lost in the
legislature in the closing days and one
of the reasons it was lost because of
the failure of the governor and the
administration and the democratic
leadership and it's in writing to lead
on that issue it had been approved by
seven six or seven standing committees
of both in the administration and the
democratic leadership and it's in
writing to lead on that issue it had
been approved by seven six or seven
standing committees of both houses of
our legislature worked out by the
industry with state government and it
went down the drain and that's too bad
that's too bad now what we've got to do
is houses of our legislature worked out
by the industry with state government
and it went down the drain and that's
too bad that's too bad now what we've
got to do is cap liability we can study
this we can study it forever but we've
got a cap toward liability and we've got
to figure out also how to protect public
servants whether they're a cap liability
we can study this we can study it
forever but we've got a cap toward
liability and we've got to figure out
also how to protect public servants
whether they're elected or whether
they're appointed how to protect them
and how to make sure that the property
taxpayers of this state don't become the
ultimate deep pocket when somebody
decides elected or whether they're
appointed how to protect them and how to
make sure that the property taxpayers of
this state don't become the ultimate
deep pocket when somebody decides to sue
a public official locally or at the
state level
i think it's time that we simply sat
down wrote the legislation and enacted
it to sue a public official locally or
at the state level
i think it's time that we simply sat
down wrote the legislation and and
enacted it governor madeline cunanan i'd
just like to reply to a statement made
by the lieutenant governor i didn't hear
him say boo about this issue when he was
lieutenant governor presiding over the
senate governor madeline cunanan i'd
just like to reply to a statement made
by the lieutenant governor i didn't hear
him say boo about this issue when he was
lieutenant governor presiding over the
senate so i don't know where his
leadership was in getting this bill out
of his senate committee senate governor
you know the fact of the matter is that
i don't know where the governor was but
we were working so i don't know where
his leadership was in getting this bill
out of his senate committee senate
governor you know the fact of the matter
is that i don't know where the governor
was but we were working around that
committee and with house leadership and
she may not remember much about the last
three days of the legislative session
because she was in her office most of
the time but this was a bill that was
around that committee and with house
leadership and she may not remember much
about the last three days of the
legislative session because she was in
her office most of the time but this was
a bill that was there people wanted it
and it didn't go and i was right up
front on it and working on it the whole
time montpelier vermont you're on go
ahead please
hello it's there people wanted it and it
didn't go and i was right up front on it
and working on it the whole time
montpelier vermont you're on go ahead
please
hello you're on the air montpelier turn
your tv set down you'll get rid of that
echo i've been teaching for 30 years
and state spending on education has
increased from you're on the air
montpelier turn your tv set down you'll
get rid of that echo i've been teaching
for 30 years
and state spending on education has
increased dramatically
but good teachers are leaving the
profession regularly
burned out very early
this simply seems dramatically
but good teachers are leaving the
profession regularly
burned out very early
there simply seems to be more state
regulations
far too many non-teaching
non-academic duties endless meetings
can the governor need more state
regulations
far too many non-teaching
non-academic duties endless meetings
can the governor tell us what we've
received in return for that spending
increase
and how the candidates feel about
education spending tell us what we've
received in return for that spending
increase
and how the candidates feel about
education spending and
caller before you go have you decided
who you're going to vote for
pardon me have you decided who you're
going to vote for no
all right thanks for the call and
excellent
caller before you go have you decided
who you're going to vote for
pardon me have you decided who you're
going to vote for no
all right thanks for the call governor
cunanan well i'm very proud of the fact
that uh vermont has been able to
increase the state's contribution for
education by 25 percent call governor
cunanan well i'm very proud of the fact
that vermont has been able to
increase the state's contribution for
education by 25 percent
and it has resulted in vermont teachers
salaries going up much faster than the
national average it has held the line on
property tax
and it has resulted in vermont teachers
salaries going up much faster than the
national average it has held the line on
property taxes and it has improved
quality
the republican opponent talks about
improving quality education but he
objects to the fact that we access and
it has improved quality uh
the republican opponent talks about
improving quality education but he
objects to the fact that we increase the
budget and we increase the budget solely
because of education you cannot have
quality education without willing to pay
for some of it now increase the budget
and we increase the budget solely
because of education you cannot have
quality education without willing to pay
for some of it now
paying
more money is not the entire answer but
neither can you do it all on rhetoric
just talking about it won't do it we
have improved
paying more money is not the entire
answer but neither can you do it all on
rhetoric just talking about it won't do
it we have improved the quality of
education in the state we got
kindergarten for every vermont school
child something that is of the essence
for early childhood education and i see
the quality of education in this state
we got kindergarten for every vermont
school child something that is of the
essence for early childhood education
and i see tremendous progress and i'm
going to continue to push for increased
funding for increased quality for
education at every single level
lieutenant governor smith
make tremendous progress and i'm going
to continue to push for increased
funding for increased quality for
education at every single level
lieutenant governor smith
i think the question was after years of
putting years of putting more money in
who was going to speak to the question
of excellence good teachers are leaving
the classroom the question was after
years of putting years of putting more
money in who is going to speak to the
question of excellence good teachers are
leaving the classroom i've served i've
had the privilege of serving on three
different national study groups the
carnegie corporation the office of
education and another one to look at the
relationship had the privilege of
serving on three different national
study groups the carnegie corporation
the office of education and another one
to look at the relationship between
teacher preparation the way teachers are
treated in the classroom and why and can
we retain good teachers and the reason
they leave is not money monies and shift
between teacher preparation the way
teachers are treated in the classroom
and why and can we retain good teachers
and the reason they leave is not money
money is fourth or fifth and it's a it's
a problem and i understand that the
reason they leave is because we don't
treat them like professionals and we
talk to 125 of our funds fourth or fifth
and it's a it's a problem and i
understand that the reason they leave is
because we don't treat them like
professionals and we talked to 125 of
our finest teachers this last spring in
vermont and what did they tell us they
said we see the problem in front of us
every day and we don't have the time
because of state regulation finest
teachers this last spring in vermont and
what did they tell us they said we see
the problem in front of us every day and
we don't have the time because of state
regulations we don't have the time to do
the educating that we're hired to do
that's why gifted teachers are leaving
the classroom my campaign will happen we
don't have the time to do the educating
that we're hired to do that's why gifted
teachers are leaving the classroom my
campaign will have specific reform
proposals to help education get better
in the classroom because that's where
teachers teach and that's where children
learn that's what specific
reform proposals to help education get
better in the classroom because that's
where teachers teach and that's where
children learn that's where they live
every day and until we make that a place
where professionals have the flexibility
to do the job they're trained and hired
and paid to do until we give them that
they live every day and until we make
that a place where professionals have
the flexibility to do the job they're
trained and hired and paid to do until
we give them that flexibility we're not
going to see education get better and
we're not going to keep good teachers in
the classroom you can't regulate your
way to excellence that's the flexibility
we're not going to see education get
better and we're not going to keep good
teachers in the classroom you can't
regulate your way to excellence that's
the path the state's been on it's
expensive in dollars and its expenses
and loss expensive and lost
opportunities for kids and it's
expensive in terms of the good teachers
that we live at this state's been on
it's expensive in dollars and its
expenses and loss expensive and lost
opportunities for kids and it's
expensive in terms of the good teachers
that we lose mayor bernard sanders i
have this figama jig in my ear and i may
have misheard what the governor said but
i wrote it down and i thought she said
that we have held the line on property
taxes mayor bernard sanders i have this
figama jig in my ear and i may have
misheard what the governor said but i
wrote it down and i thought she said
that we have held the line on property
taxes i live in the state of vermont
that is not my perception of the reality
that's going on in the state this year
according to vermont league of cities
and towns property taxes went up by 28.
i live in the state of vermont that is
not my perception of the reality that's
going on in the state this year
according to vermont league of cities
and towns property taxes went up by 28
million dollars in the last five years
i'm guessing a minimum of 100 million
dollar increase in burlington alone
because of the disastrous state
education formula we raise property
million dollars in the last five years
i'm guessing a minimum of 100 million
dollar increase in burlington alone
because of the disastrous state aid
education formula we raise property
taxes for education by 1.7 million
dollars what has got to happen there is
a crisis in this state and i want to
talk about it for a moment because i
think it's perhaps the most important
issue in taxes for education by 1.7
million
what has got to happen there is a crisis
in this state i want to talk about it
for a moment because i think it's
perhaps the most important issue that
we're going to have to be dealing with
we saw it in hinesburg last year we saw
it in south burlington this year on one
side you have teachers and you have
school boards who want that we're going
to have to be dealing with we saw it in
hinesburg last year we saw it in south
burlington this year on one side you
have teachers and you have school boards
who want absolutely correctly decent
quality education for the kids on the
other side you have working people
farmers poor people who simply cannot
afford higher and higher absolutely
correctly decent quality education for
the kids on the other side you have
working people farmers poor people who
simply cannot afford higher and higher
property taxes to fund education and
every year we're seeing school budgets
turn downs we're seeing communities
bitterly divided by this issue we will
property taxes to fund education and
every year we're seeing school budgets
turn downs we're seeing communities
bitterly divided by this issue we will
have a proposal which will be based on
prop a progressive taxation
which will significantly increase state
eight education governor cunanan
increased it this year by to have a
proposal which will be based on prop a
progressive taxation
which will significantly increase state
eight education governor cunanan
increased it this year by 10 million
dollars that's something it's a start
but it is nowhere near enough we still
continue to lag far behind the rest of
this country in terms of state aid to
education second million dollars that's
something it's a start but it is nowhere
near enough we still continue to lag far
behind the rest of this country in terms
of state aid to education second of all
we've got to have direct property tax
relief with decoupling and progressive
taxation we can do both and that's what
i intend to do as if elected governor
manchester united we've got to have
direct property tax relief with
decoupling and progressive taxation we
can do both and that's what i intend to
do as if elected governor manchester new
hampshire your next caller go ahead
please yes i'm calling from new
hampshire and a major concern to me is
the race in new hampshire concerning
nuclear power new hampshire your next
caller go ahead please
yes i'm calling from new hampshire and a
major concern to me is the race in new
hampshire concerning nuclear power
recently governor sununu
at the uh the governor's council
was
stated that he was willing to spend a
lot of money recently governor sununu at
the uh the governor's council
was
stated that he was willing to spend a
lot of money to defeat a resolution
proposed by governor coonan of
vermont i'd like to have
some talk about that from all three
campaigning to defeat a resolution um
proposed by governor coonan of uh
vermont um i'd like to have a uh some
talk about that from all three
candidates
all right thanks for the call governor
cunanan
thank you actually it wasn't to defeat
the resolution it was to defeat me so
that i think that was uh
all right thanks for the call governor
cunanan
thank you actually it wasn't to defeat
the resolution it was to defeat me so
that i think that was uh that was the
aftermath of the resolution having been
passed i think we just have a very
different view
about nuclear power between the governor
of new hampshire that was the aftermath
of the resolution having been passed i
think we just have a very different view
about nuclear power between the governor
of new hampshire and myself i offered
the resolution that asked the congress
to hold hearings on giving the states
more authority over the safety of
nuclear and myself i offered the
resolution that asked the congress to
hold hearings on giving the states more
authority over the safety of nuclear
power plants that doesn't mean we should
take over the function of the nrc but it
does mean that if our citizens want a
higher standard of safety we should be
permitted to do power plants that
doesn't mean we should take over the
function of the nrc but it does mean
that if our citizens want a higher
standard of safety we should be
permitted to do that in certain areas
just as we do in certain environmental
areas and that's where we disagree the
governor of new hampshire
has saddled with seabrook as you know
that in certain areas just as we do in
certain environmental areas and that's
where we disagree the governor of new
hampshire
is saddled with seabrook as you know and
he took this very personally as an
attack on seabrook it was not it was my
purpose to make sure that our vermont
nuclear power plant is safe and i ain't
owe and he took this very personally as
an attack on seabrook it was not it was
my purpose to make sure that our vermont
nuclear power plant is safe and i intend
to continue in that vein to make certain
that states do have some authority
because in the end we have the final
responsibility of determining whether or
not a plan is safe and to continue in
that vein to make certain that states do
have some authority because in the end
we have the final responsibility of
determining whether or not a plan is
safe and if we don't have any preview to
that to add to the level of safety our
authority is fairly empty in some of our
programming here from montpelier and
talk if we don't have any preview to
that to add to the level of safety our
authority is fairly empty in some of our
programming here from montpelier and
talking about this specific issue it
keeps coming up again and again this
tension between governor cunanan and
governor sununu has it been there for
your two years in office what's the
history behind this
about this specific issue it keeps
coming up again and again this tension
between governor cunanan and governor
sununu has it been there for your two
years in office what's the history
behind this
well we're very different states and
obviously we're a different party and we
take a different view on things but i
don't think it's a tension that pervades
everything and it shouldn't well we're
very different states and obviously
we're a different party and we take a
different view on things but i don't
think it's a tension that pervades
everything and it shouldn't i certainly
look forward to working cooperatively on
many other issues we share a river we
share bridges we have
many things in common but on certain i
certainly look forward to working
cooperatively on many other issues we
share a river we share bridges we have
many things in common but on certain
issues and basic values i think we are
different there also was a question as
to how much money governor john sununu
said he would raise to defeat you was it
a million dollars
that's what an issue is in basic values
i think we are different there also was
a question as to how much money governor
john sununu said he would raise to
defeat you was it a million dollars
that's what uh that's what he told one
of my aides he did not tell me directly
he was talking to a staff person but
there are other people who heard that
figure quoted lieutenant governor smith
any comment about uh that's what he told
one of my aides he did not tell me
directly he was talking to a staff
person but there are other people who
heard that figure quoted lieutenant
governor smith any comment about the
question about nuclear power well i
think it's important first of all to
assure you regretfully that i haven't
received the check yet
and i've got the question about nuclear
power well i think it's important first
of all to
assure you regretfully that i haven't
received the check yet
and of course
it would be in violation of the law to
be in violation of the law and i think
it's too serious a subject to joke about
this story good to look at where it came
from of course
it would be in violation of the law to
be in violation of the law and i think
it's too serious a subject to joke about
this story good look at where it came
from it came from the cunan
administration and it came the day after
i had alerted people of this state
excuse me governor i'm talking uh and it
came the day after i'm from the cuny
administration and it came the day after
i had alerted people in this state
excuse me governor i'm talking uh and it
came the day after i notified people
that they were going to lose a 16
million dollar tax cut and the
administration and the governor's
campaign didn't want people to think
about that too much i notified people
that they were going to lose a 16
million dollar tax cut and the
administration and the governor's
campaign didn't want people to think
about that too much so what they did was
leak a story
okay that's what happened it was i
wasn't present in the conversation
neither were any members of the press
so what they did was leak a story
okay that's what happened it was i
wasn't present in the conversation
neither were any members of the press
this was news media manufacturing pure
and simple and governor sununu and the
governor of vermont may disagree or they
may agree but the fact of the matter is
that has it was news media manufacturing
pure and simple and governor sununu and
the governor of vermont may disagree or
they may agree but the fact of the
matter is that has excuse me
and then i'll let you respond i would
like if you don't want to say a word too
the fact excuse me
the fact of the matter is what a
surprise
the fact of the matter is that i don't
know what was said there and neither
does she and neither does the media but
of course
what a surprise
the fact of the matter is that i don't
know what was said there and neither
does she and neither does the media but
of course he's not going to be involved
in this campaign i'm involved in this
game campaign i'm running it and if i'm
governor i'm going to have my hands on
the state of vermont government and i'm
going to roars he's not going to be
involved in this campaign i'm involved
in this game
campaign i'm running it and if i'm
governor i'm going to have my hands on
the state of vermont government and i'm
going to run that every day too i set
the rule that everybody would be able to
respond so mayor why don't you go ahead
next
i think
peter picked up on a point which is an
interesting point is is on that every
day too i set the rule that everybody
would be able to respond so mayor why
don't you go ahead next
i think
peter picked up on a point which is an
interesting point is is
and that is this the governor was at a
governor's conference and i watched some
of that i must say on your c-span i
watch this thing now and then and it's
it's it's a good program and one of the
things the one learns that the governor
and that is this the governor was at a
governor's conference and i watched some
of that i must say on your c-span i
watch this thing now and then and it's
it's a good program and one of the
things that one learns at a governance
conference is that you have 50 governors
running down each one going back to the
states telling about all the important
resolutions that are almost unanimously
passed
it's good i mean frankly mayors do this
at conferences they have 50 governors
running down each one going back to the
states telling about all the important
resolutions that are almost unanimously
passed it's good i mean frankly mayors
do this occasionally too i do admit that
but i think the issue here is not
primarily
resolutions past the governor's
conference expressing concern about
nuclear power occasionally too i do
admit that but i think the issue here is
not primarily
resolutions past the governor's
conference expressing concern about
nuclear power or the governor is quite
right i want to see the state of vermont
have far more power determining the
safety of that nuclear power plant
really once again what the issue is not
mr sununu's
the governor is quite right i want to
see the state of vermont have far more
power determining the safety of that
nuclear power plant really once again
what the issue is not mr sununu's
million dollars believe me i don't think
a million dollars is going to come into
this campaign like peter i have not yet
received the check either i think really
the issue gets back to
nuclear power and the issue is in
dollars believe me i don't think a
million dollars is going to come into
this campaign like peter i have not yet
received the check either i think really
the issue gets back to
nuclear power and the issue is not
resolutions not concerned every person
in the state of vermont is concerned
everybody's everybody appears every sane
human being is frightened about this
technology not resolutions not concerned
every person in the state of vermont is
concerned everybody's everybody appears
every sane human being is frightened
about this technology the issue is do we
say no or do we express concern that's
really what the issue of nuclear power
is about governor i just like to set the
record straight because uh the
lieutenant governor's remark the issue
is do we say no or do we express concern
that's really what the issue of nuclear
power is about governor i'd just like to
set the record straight because the
lieutenant governor's remarks seem to
imply that this was not accurate
my staff does not tell things to me that
are not true
there were many witnesses to that and
actually seemed to imply that this was
not accurate uh my staff does not tell
things to me that are not true uh there
were many witnesses to that and actually
when the press went to governor sununu
he did not deny it he only said he
didn't know where he'd find a million
dollars so
i think that's uh
frankly i was flatly when the press went
to governor sununu he did not deny it he
only said he didn't know where he'd find
a million dollars so
i think that's uh
frankly i was flattered by the whole
thing i thought it's overblown the whole
point is states should have some control
over their nuclear power plants and some
say in the safety question there's a
voter waiting by the whole thing i
thought it's overblown the whole point
is states should have some control over
their nuclear power plants and some say
in the safety question there's a voter
waiting but lieutenant governor i didn't
say it wasn't accurate governor i said
you manufactured the news and you did it
in a very effective way to keep people
from thinking about a very real thing
with lieutenant governor i didn't say it
was an accurate governor
i said you manufactured the news and you
did it in a very effective way to keep
people from thinking about a very real
problem raised by your administration
working men and women in this state
aren't going to get a 17 million dollar
tax cut and the state personal income
tax that they would have gotten problem
raised by your administration working
men and women in this state aren't going
to get a 17 million dollar tax cut in
the state personal income tax that they
would have gotten if you'd followed the
deficit reduction spending cap that's
what i said it was manufactured by your
administration i didn't say it was
inaccurate it was good time with that if
you'd followed the deficit reduction
spending cap that's what i said it was
manufactured by your administration i
didn't say it was inaccurate it was good
time with that we'll move on burlington
vermont good evening go ahead please
yes i'd like to direct this question to
the mayor until the governor
do you believe move on burlington
vermont good evening go ahead please
yes i'd like to direct this question to
the meyer and to the governor
do you believe that the
governor has delivered
on her promises to the people of the
city of burlington
the margie that the
governor has delivered
on her promises to the people of the
city of burlington
the margin of her victory in the last
election
very clearly came from the city of
burlington and it's not terribly clear
that all of the
victory in the last election uh very
clearly came from the city of burlington
and it's not terribly clear that all of
the
referenda and so on that were passed by
the people of the city the governor
acted expeditiously upon and thereby
perhaps caused the
referenda and so on but repressed by the
people of the city the governor acted
expeditiously upon
and thereby perhaps cost the people of
the city of burlington a good deal of
taxpayer money that's my question
mayor sanders well obviously i'm a
little bit prejudiced here because i am
the mayor of the
city of burlington a good deal of
taxpayer money that's my question
mayor sanders well obviously i'm a
little bit prejudiced here because i am
the mayor of the city of burlington and
more importantly though i think the real
issue is not whether the governor has
has kept the promises to the people of
burlington it's basically whether the
governor has acted up the city of
burlington and more importantly though i
think the real issue is not whether the
governor has has kept the promises to
the people of burlington it's basically
whether the governor has acted
appropriately for all of the cities and
towns in the state of vermont
as the mayor of the largest city in the
state as a member of the vermont league
of cities and towns for the last five
years let me say inappropriately for all
of the cities and towns in the state of
vermont
as the mayor of the largest city in the
state as a member of the vermont league
of cities and towns for the last five
years let me say emphatically in my view
the community administration has not
done that let me give two examples
specifically in terms of the state aid
education formula that formula is
identically in my view the community
administration has not done that let me
give two examples specifically in terms
of the state aid to education formula
that formula is a disaster that formula
is a disaster not only for the city of
burlington where we get approximately
one hundred dollars per kid as opposed
to some communities in the state of
vermont disaster that formula is a
disaster not only for the city of
burlington where we get approximately
one hundred dollars per kid as opposed
to some communities in the state of
vermont which get two thousand dollars a
kid now honest people can disagree about
what makes a decent state eight
education formula okay what's right but
no one will convince which get two
thousand dollars a kid now honest people
can disagree about what makes a decent
state education formula okay what's
right but no one will convince me that
one community getting 20 times more than
another community is right in burlington
we get a hundred bucks a kid we had to
raise property taxes 1.7 million dollars
last year to me that one community
getting 20 times more than another
community is right in burlington we get
100 bucks a kid we had to raise property
taxes 1.7 million dollars last year
precisely because of the state education
formula but that's not just burlington
alone second of all second of all the
state of vermont last year again as
mayor of the city i am precisely because
of the state education formula but
that's not just burlington alone second
of all second of all the state of
vermont last year again as mayor of the
city i am very involved in this talk to
other city officials we lost in the
state of vermont because of the reagan
administrations and the congresses
democratic republican congress disaster
very involved in this talk to other city
officials we lost in the state of
vermont because of the reagan
administrations and the congresses
democratic republican congress
disastrous set of priorities 12 to 13
million dollars in revenue sharing this
is money which in our community went
into police and fire protection into
other communities that went into other
set of priorities 12 to 13 million
dollars in revenue sharing this is money
which in our community went into police
and fire protection into other
communities that went into other
important civic needs
what we demanded what the league of
cities and towns put as their top
priority was governor help us replace
important civic needs
what we demanded with the league of
cities and towns put as their top
priority was governor help us replace
this loss of revenue sharing so that we
do not have to raise property taxes that
did not happen that was the major
priority of the vermont league of cities
and towns so i would answer that
question by saying this loss of revenue
sharing so that we do not have to raise
property taxes that did not happen that
was the major priority of the vermont
league of cities and towns so i would
answer that question by saying no the
governor has not been responsive to the
needs of the people the city of
burlingame but as governor of the state
she has 245 other cities and towns to
worry about not just burlington in my
view the more important thing no the
governor has not been responsive to the
needs of the people the city of
burlingame but as governor of the state
she has 245 other cities and towns to
worry about not just burlington in my
view the more important answer is that
in terms of the relationship between
state government and local government in
general
we have been in a disastrous situation
property taxes are rising the answer is
that in terms of the relationship
between state government and local
government in general
we have been in a disastrous situation
property taxes are rising very rapidly
and the cuny administration in my view
has not been responsible governor
cunanan
i find myself in an interesting position
with the mayor saying i should be
spending a whole very rapidly and the
cuny administration in my view has not
been responsible governor cunanan
i find myself in an interesting position
with the mayor saying i should be
spending a whole lot more money and the
lieutenant governor
saying i've spent too much money as a
matter of fact i'm glad he does realize
that i have a responsibility as governor
to all of the lot more money and the
lieutenant governor saying i've spent
too much money as a matter of fact i'm
allowed he does realize that i have a
responsibility as governor to all of the
people in this state and i think we did
just the right thing we increase state
aid to education i like to reply to the
lieutenant governor who keeps repeating
the people in this state and i think we
did just the right thing we increased
state aid to education i like to reply
to the lieutenant governor who keeps
repeating this fact that we uh we
increased spending and therefore uh did
uh closed an opportunity as he puts it
we increase spending for a fact that we
uh we increase spending and therefore uh
did closed an opportunity as he puts it
we increase spending for education and
that is money exactly well spent and if
we had not done that we would not have
the quality education he would like
education and that is money exactly well
spent and if we had not done that we
would not have the quality education he
would like to have in theory but is not
willing to put into effect in practice
and we would have even higher property
taxes now burlington because it is
considered at height to have in theory
but is not willing to put into effect in
practice and we would have even higher
property taxes now burlington because it
is considered a higher than average
income town the mayor is correct did not
benefit from that increase in state aid
but i can name you town after town after
town better than average income town the
mayor is correct did not benefit from
that increase in state aid but i can
name you town after town after town that
benefited substantially from that
increase in state aid held down its
property taxes increased its quality of
education and i believe i benefited
substantially from that increase in
state aid held down its property taxes
increased its quality of education and i
believe i totally
fulfilled my commitment in that regard i
promised a 25 increase in state aid and
i delivered a 25 increase in state aid i
totally
fulfilled my commitment in that regard i
promised a 25 increase in state aid and
i delivered a 25 increase in state aid i
promised to retire the deficit and i did
retire the deficit you can always talk
about spending you could always talk
about cutting it's easy to talk about
cutting promise to retire the deficit
and i did retire the deficit you can
always talk about spending you could
always talk about cutting it's easy to
talk about cutting but let's be specific
where mr smith would you have cut that
budget
lieutenant governor smith
i'm glad you asked yes you know the fact
of the matter but let's be specific
where mr smith would you have cut that
budget
lieutenant governor smith
i'm glad you asked yes you know the fact
of the matter is and let me go a little
farther with some of the numbers that i
used earlier we've increased spending 63
million dollars in this state there is
and let me go a little farther with some
of the numbers that i used earlier we've
increased spending 63 million dollars in
this state in the last two years the
governor would have you believe that her
17.8 million dollar increase in state
aid to education is the reason in the
last two years the governor which have
you believe that her 17.8 million dollar
increase in state aid to education is
the reason
that's the reason why your personal
income tax isn't going to go down but
the numbers just don't bear it out the
fact is there would have been a little
less money for state aid to education
that's the reason why your personal
income tax isn't going to go down but
the numbers just don't bear it out the
fact is there would have been a little
less money for state aid to education
but let's take a look at where that
money really went it went to 200 plus
new state employees at a time when other
state employees weren't able to get a
labor contract that they should but
let's take a look at where that money
really went it went to 200 plus new
state employees at a time when other
state employees weren't able to get a
labor contract that they thought was a
good one 200 new people built into the
state budget at 25 000 a year in
perpetuity forever numbers of nuke
thought was a good one 200 new people
built into the state budget at 25 000 a
year in perpetuity forever
numbers of new programs started the fact
is governor the public relations
rhetoric sounds good
but it wasn't a trade between education
funding and an income tax program
started the fact is governor the public
relations rhetoric sounds good
but it wasn't a trade between education
funding and an income tax cut it just
wasn't the numbers don't show it so
that's in fact the plan was there and
you've said i was right but a couple of
times the plan was there to limit but it
just wasn't the numbers don't show it so
that's it in fact the plan was there and
you've said i was right but a couple of
times the plan was there to limit
spending to six percent now excuse me
i've already told you we would have not
increased state employees 200 of them we
would have not started some of the new
programming to six percent now excuse me
i've already told you we would have not
increased state employees 200 of them we
would have not started some of the new
programs and we would have put a little
bit more into state aid and then we'd be
able to take the highest tax rate
combined in the united states of america
one of the three highest and one of the
programs and we would have put a little
bit more into state aid and then we'd be
able to take the highest tax rate
combined in the united states of america
one of the three highest and one of the
poorest states and reduce it i think
that would have been real progress i'm
going to hold you there mr sanders you
had something you wanted to throw very
much okay the governor made an
interesting point she said states and
reduce it i think that would have been
real progress i'm going to hold you
there mr sanders you had something you
wanted very much okay the governor made
an interesting point she's sitting here
in the middle and being hit by mr smith
and being hit by me it's a tough life
but here's what the point is governor
and i would hope that you would respond
to this as a result of waiting here in
the middle and being hit by mr smith and
being hit by me it's a tough life but
here's what the point is governor and i
would hope that you would respond to
this
as a result of reagan's tax breaks to
wealthy people and corporations
we have lost as a state close to 300
million dollars of tax revenue in the
last six years begins tax breaks to
wealthy people and corporations
we have lost as a state close to 300
million dollars of tax revenue in the
last six years the issue is not spending
and the issue is not taxation the issue
is who is paying the taxes and where is
the money going that's really what the
issue is what we know the issue is not
spending and the issue is not taxation
the issue is who is paying the taxes and
where is the money going that's really
what the issue is what we know right now
is that wealthy people and corporations
in the state of vermont are paying less
than they paid five years ago in
combined state and federal taxes we know
right now is that wealthy people and
corporations in the state of vermont are
paying less than they paid five years
ago in combined state and federal taxes
we know that homeowners and poor people
are paying significantly more in
property taxes so what you're seeing in
the state of vermont there's an
interesting tax situation wealthy people
corporations pay that homeowners and
poor people are paying significantly
more in property taxes so what you're
seeing in the state of vermont is an
interesting tax situation wealthy people
corporations paying less
in personal and corporate income tax
home owners low income people paying
more in property taxes what we are
proposing is serious tax reform which
less
in personal and corporate income tax
homeowners low income people paying more
in property taxes what we are proposing
is serious tax reform which both
governor cunanan lieutenant governor
smith are running away from we are
saying and will demonstrate that in
point the fact we can lower the property
tax burden on home both governor cuny
and lieutenant governor smith are
running away from we are saying and will
demonstrate that in point the fact we
can lower the property tax burden on
homeowners in the state by 20 percent we
can significantly increase state aid to
education far more than what the
governor is talking about
and we can do this owners in the state
by 20 percent we can significantly
increase state aid to education far more
than what the governor is talking about
and we can do this without having
anybody in the state of vermont not the
richest person in the state of vermont
paying more in combined state and
federal taxes than they paid five years
ago i think that's the direct without
having anybody in the state of vermont
not the richest person in the state of
vermont paying more in combined state
and federal taxes than they paid five
years ago i think that's the direction
we should go but we're gonna have to
have the guts to create a tax system
here in the state of vermont and not let
washington make the tax laws for there
governor cunanan i would just add one we
should go but we're going to have to
have the guts to create a tax system
here in the state of vermont and not let
washington make the tax laws
just add foreign very important note
this administration is going to enable
the state of vermont to have the biggest
tax cut in its history 20 million
dollars as a result of getting very
important note this administration is
going to enable the state of vermont to
have the biggest tax cut in its history
20 million dollars as a result of
getting rid of the surcharge that we
enacted earlier because we retired the
deficit and lived within our means now
the mayor talks about 300 million
dollars with the surcharge that we
enacted earlier because we retired the
deficit and lived within our means now
the mayor talks about 300 million
dollars uh simply uh getting that from
the corporations and the rich that's a
mythology there aren't those kinds of
corporations there aren't those kinds of
rich people those are simply getting
that from the corporations and the rich
that's a mythology there aren't those
kinds of corporations there aren't those
kinds of rich people those are
vermonters who pay those taxes in their
middle income vermonters so it's easy to
talk in theory and pinpoint evil at some
distant place but the vermonters who pay
those taxes and their middle income
vermonters so it's easy to talk in
theory and pinpoint evil at some distant
place but the vermont economy the
vermont taxpayer isn't made up that way
you would be taking that money out of
the pockets of vermonters it isn't done
with blue smoke and mirrors not economy
the vermont taxpayer isn't made up that
way you would be taking that money out
of the pockets of vermonters it isn't
done with blue smoke and mirrors a lot
of callers who want to get through a lot
of questions to answer so sarasota
florida your next go ahead please
terrorism and second home development a
lot of callers we want to get through a
lot of questions to answer so sarasota
florida your next go ahead please
tourism and second home development in
the ski industry are very important to
the vermont economy and as a former
vermonter i'm interested in knowing if
the candidates plan to support these
industries ski industries are very
important to the vermont economy and as
a former vermonter i'm interested in
knowing if the candidates plan to
support these industries by encouraging
increases in state dollars for tourist
promotion
lieutenant governor smith
[Applause]
excuse me thank you by encouraging
increases in state dollars for tourist
promotion lieutenant governor smith
[Applause]
excuse me thank you for the question
the fact of the matter is that i've
already said in my campaign that
increasing combining the existing
promotional budgets we have here for the
question
the fact of the matter is that i've
already said in my campaign
that increasing combining the existing
promotional budgets we have in the state
of vermont so going to have one
integrated promotion for vermont so we
have get better bang for the dollar
quite frankly and then increasing that
promotion budget is one in the state of
vermont so going to have one integrated
promotion for vermont so we have get
better bang for the dollar quite frankly
and then increasing that promotion
budget is one of the things i'm going to
do travel industry tourist industry
included you know why because it's an
industry in this state that's an
investment that will increase state
revenues the things i'm going to do
travel industry tourist industry
included you know why because it's an
industry in this state that's an
investment that will increase state
revenues it will affect if we increase
the bed count in our hotels existing
hotels and motels in the state of
vermont not a new sewer pipe not a new
electric wire not a new it will affect
if we increase the bed count in our
hotels existing hotels and motels in the
state of vermont not a new sewer pipe
not an electric wire not a new room if
we just increased the people in those
beds by 10 percent over a year we'd have
something like 40 million dollars of
business revenue we'd have a thousand
new job room if we just increased the
people in those beds by 10 over a year
we'd have something like 40 million
dollars of business revenue we'd have a
thousand new jobs two million dollars
new state revenue
you know the 100 new businesses so it's
an investment that'll pay back you know
it's simply times jobs 2 million new
state revenue
you know
100 new businesses so it's an investment
that'll pay back you know it's simply
time for us to understand when i talked
about the question will people who have
to work for a living be able to continue
to live in vermont's countryside we talk
about the kind of for us to understand
when i talked about the question will
people who have to work for a living be
able to continue to live in vermont's
countryside we talk about the kind of
diverse economy we need to support
people the travel industry is part of
that and an important part of that i
would also tell you that i ran and i was
the only candidate first economy we need
to support people the travel industry is
part of that and an important part of
that i would also tell you that iran and
i was the only candidate in 1984 who ran
on a platform that included a way to
control rapid growth and i'm going to do
that again this year but i can tell you
my plan isn't going to be us in 1984 who
ran on a platform that included a way to
control rapid growth and i'm going to do
that again this year but i can tell you
my plan isn't going to be a statewide
land use plan approach my plan is going
to be a way that strengthens local
communities strengthens local decision
makers strengthens local planning boards
because that's the way to give people
statewide land use plan approach my plan
is going to be a way that strengthens
local communities strengthens local
decision makers strengthens local
planning boards because that's the way
to give people power you don't give
communities power by taking it away to
the state level we've got a good program
and we're going to keep it up the answer
is yes to your question on travel mayor
sanders power you don't give communities
power by taking it away to the state
level we've got a good program and we're
going to keep it up the answer is yes to
your question on travel mayor sanders
question is a good question and my
answer is this tourism is clearly an
important part of vermont's economy and
in burlington obviously as mayor of the
city
question is a good question and my
answer is this tourism is clearly an
important part of vermont's economy and
in burlington obviously as mayor of the
city i entered many many negotiations
with people in the business community
what we do not do in burlington is give
away people's tax dollars to wealthy
people and corporations or would be
entered many many negotiations with
people in the business community what we
do not do in burlington is give away
people's tax dollars to wealthy people
and corporations or would be the case
the fiber governor to the ski industry
because they're clamoring and because
they need more money everybody needs
more money what you sit down and you do
is you negotiate and you say the case
the fiber governor to the ski industry
because they're clamoring and because
they need more money everybody needs
more money what you sit down and you do
is you negotiate and you say
if we give you this kind of money what
are we going to get back in terms of
decent paying jobs what are we going to
get back in terms of tax revenue and if
you strike a good bargain if we give you
this kind of money what are we going to
get back in terms of decent paying jobs
what are we going to get back in terms
of tax revenue and if you strike a good
bargain you go for it and if you don't
strike a good bargain you don't go for
it i don't want to see poor and working
people subsidizing wealthy people who
happen to own the tourist industry
second of all as you go for it and if
you don't strike a good bargain you
don't go for it i don't want to see poor
and working people subsidizing wealthy
people who happen to own the tourist
industry second of all as important as
the tourist industry is you know what
industry is even more important in the
state of vermont that we're not
adequately funding and that is
agriculture i think i'm the only
important as the tourist industry is you
know what industry is even more
important in the state of vermont that
we're not adequately funding and that is
agriculture i think i'm the only
candidate up here who believes that the
family farm is viable it is not obsolete
and that we've got the fight like hell
to maintain the family farm between you
and me candidate up here who believes
that the family farm is viable it is not
obsolete and that we've got the fight
like hell to maintain the family farm
between you and me frankly would i
rather see money go into agriculture so
that we can have honest hard-working
farmers continue the 200-year tradition
of this state would i rather give the
money to the ski industry frankly would
i rather see money go into agriculture
so that we could have honest
hard-working farmers continue the
200-year tradition of the state would i
rather give the money to the ski
industry i'd rather give it to the
farmers governor madeleine cunanan i
would argue that the mayor is the only
candidate who has fought for the farmer
we have very strongly fought for them
i'd rather give it to the farmers
governor madeleine cunanan i would argue
that the mayor is the only candidate who
has fought for the farmer
we have very strongly fought for the
farmer and in fact uh provided a
very sound program in terms of uh tax
relief by the current use tax program
which uh allowed the farmer in fact uh
provided a
very sound program in terms of tax
relief by the current use tax program
which allows a farmer to have his or her
land evaluated at its use rather than
it's fair market value but i think the
question was about tourism they are
interrelated in the same sounds of
farmer to have his or her land evaluated
at its use rather than its fair market
value but i think the question was about
tourism they are interrelated in the
sense that a lot of people come to
vermont because of the beauty of our
open spaces and our farmland and i i
guess this isn't quite cricket but i'd
like to use this opportunity against
that a lot of people come to vermont
because of the beauty of our open spaces
and our farmland and i i guess this
isn't quite cricket but i'd like to use
this opportunity to encourage anybody
who's listening to think of vermont as a
place to actually see that for
themselves that as far as advertising
for the state i to encourage anybody
who's listening to think of vermont as a
place to actually see that for
themselves that as far as advertising
for the state i believe that it should
be on a matching basis that when the
state promotes advertising to some
degree the private sector should share i
believe that it should be on a matching
basis that when the state promotes
advertising to some degree the private
sector should share
in that expenditure but i also note with
interest that the lieutenant governor
who constantly talks about how he would
cut the budget is very quick to increase
the in that expenditure but i also note
with interest that the lieutenant
governor who constantly talks about how
he would cut the budget is very quick to
increase the budget whenever a
particular group makes a request such as
the tourism sector perhaps okay i think
i'd get the senate governor very quickly
the fact of the matter is that i gave
the record whenever a particular group
makes a request such as the tourism
sector perhaps okay
senate governor very quickly the fact of
the matter is that i gave the rationale
and it makes excellent business sense if
we can spend a little bit more money and
raise five or six times as much and
those are standard figures then in fact
especially with national and it makes
excellent business sense if we can spend
a little bit more money and raise five
or six times as much and those are
standard figures then in fact especially
when you look at the times we're going
into where i think it's going to be
tougher to come by state revenues
because we've spent our way into a hole
in this state that kind of a little
investment makes some sense you look at
the times we're going into where i think
it's going to be tougher to come by
state revenues because we've spent our
way into a hole in this state that kind
of a little investment makes some sense
the other thing i got to tell you is
when i talk to farmers and i talk to
members of the travel industry they know
they need each other they know it and
they say where the [ __ ] the other thing
i got to tell you is when i talk to
farmers and i talk to members of the
travel industry they know they need each
other they know it and they say where'd
the fight come from farmer told me the
other day i need these people to come to
vermont and the travel industry people
know that the fact of the matter is the
mayor nor the governor owns i come from
farmer told me the other day i need
these people to come to vermont and the
travel industry people know that the
fact of the matter is the mayor nor the
governor owns the owns love of
agriculture we've got a proposal and it
addresses two major things one how do
you help farmers reduce the cost of
doing business it's the owns love of
agriculture we've got a proposal and it
addresses two major things one how do
you help farmers reduce the cost of
doing business and the other is how to
help farmers develop new products and
market the products they've got we've
had trouble frankly in the marketing
program and we think we can do something
about it the other is how do you help
farmers develop new products and market
the products they've got we've had
trouble frankly in the marketing program
and we think we can do something about
it that won't cost a whole lot of news
there's a vermont voter waiting on the
line but mayor sanders go ahead 10
seconds went on a little bit long i
think it must be this thing in my ear
again but i thought i heard the governor
say that won't cost a whole lot of news
there's a vermont voter waiting on the
line but mayor sanders go ahead ten
seconds went on a little bit longer i
think it must be this thing in my ear
again but i thought i heard the governor
say we fought
to bring about uh tax reform for the
farmers actually correct
gee i must have missed the boat on this
i thought you were opposed we fought
to bring about uh tax reform for the
farmers actually correct
gee i must have missed the vote on this
i thought you were opposed to it for the
entire session of the legislature and
just came into support of it at the very
end of the legion in fact i'm quite
certain of that in fact i'm quite
certain that it was anthony polina into
it for the entire session of the
legislature and just came into support
of it at the very end of the legion in
fact i'm quite certain of that in fact
i'm quite certain that it was anthony
polina and the people working for the
fair tax initiative of which i was
involved in who said that the farmers of
the state of vermont need property tax
relief if my memory is a right you did
not support that of the people working
for the fair tax initiative of which i
was involved in who said that the
farmers of the state of vermont need
property tax relief if my memory is a
right you did not support that until the
very end of the legislature when we
developed the momentum to bring it into
effect that's what my memory is maybe my
ear plug is doing me misjustice governor
cunanan with a vermont voter waiting
until the very end of the legislature
when we developed the momentum to bring
it into effect that's what my memory is
maybe my ear plug is doing me misjustice
governor cunanan with a vermont voter
waiting go ahead i don't want to keep
that vermont voter waiting but before
you were mayor bernie i was chairman of
the appropriations committee when we
enacted that law and i've been ahead i
don't want to keep that vermont voter
waiting but before you were mayor bernie
i was chairman of the appropriations
committee when we enacted that law and
i've been strongly supportive of that
ever since we opened up the current use
program we've held hearings throughout
the state we're going to triple the
amount of money in that program and
that's the greatest strongly supportive
of that ever since we opened up the
current use program we've held hearings
throughout the state we're going to
triple the amount of money in that
program and that's the greatest
assistance for the short time that we
can give them
when
but when you were governor is really
what we're talking about whatever times
whenever c-span travels on the road like
this there's a latest assistance for the
short time that we can give them not
when you were in the legislature but
when you were governor is really what
we're talking about whatever
whenever c-span travels on the road like
this there's a lot of people that help
us out we're operating on strange turf
and a lot of people help us out and it's
only way we can do that i'd like to
thank mr ed weed director of engineering
and supervisor of the buildings and a
lot of people that help us out we're
operating on strange turf and a lot of
people help us out and it's the only way
we can do that i'd like to thank mr ed
weed director of engineering and
supervisor of the buildings and grounds
for the state for helping us and also
green mountain cable for their
assistance and helping us pull this off
here in montpelier vermont let's go to
that grounds for the state for helping
us and also green mountain cable for
their assistance and helping us pull
this off here in montpelier vermont
let's go to that that voter norwich
you're on the air go ahead please yes
good evening thank you for the
opportunity to call
i wanted to ask the
three candidates
voter norwich you're on the air go ahead
please yes good evening thank you for
the opportunity to call
i wanted to ask the
three candidates
what their positions would be
uh are on
ensuring the fair access
to the home satellite
what their positions would be
are on
ensuring the fair access
to the home satellite
viewers like myself who are numerous in
the state of vermont to see that we can
continue to see this program and all the
other programs
viewers like myself who are numerous in
the state of vermont to see that we can
continue to see this program and and all
the other programming uh that
hasn't been available to us until the
advent of satellites and
what your positions would be and uh
seeing that this ring that
hasn't been available to us until the
advent of satellites and
what your positions would be and uh
seeing that this right is uh insured in
the future and i think you know it's uh
one of the wonders of satellite
technology that this program tonight is
taking place as ensured in the future
and i think you know
it's
one of the wonders of satellite
technology that this program tonight is
taking place and that uh callers from
vermont and florida
and the virgin islands and california
could all get together and discuss this
and it's an issue that's certainly in
front race and that uh callers from
vermont and florida
and the virgin islands and california
could all get together and discuss this
and it's an issue that's certainly in
front of the congress but political
pressure from
uh from the state level and uh
certainly of interest to me and i'm sure
many vermonters but the congress but
political pressure from
uh from the state level and uh
certainly of interest to me and i'm sure
many vermonters as well as many of the
viewers tonight so i'd be interested in
hearing your opinions and i'm be hanging
up well before you go let me ask you are
there a lot of home dish owners in this
state um as well as many of the viewers
tonight so i'd be interested in hearing
your opinions and i'll be hanging up
norwich before you go let me ask you are
there a lot of home dish owners in this
state um
they're all over the place i'm sure
the three candidates know there was some
legislation uh
in front of the uh
vermont house this past year
they're all over the place i'm sure
the three candidates know there was some
legislation
in front of the uh
vermont house this past year regarding
home dish
displacement and luckily that was
either thrown out or defeated but
yeah the dishes are
really are regarding home vision
displacement and luckily that was either
thrown out or defeated but
yeah the dishes are
really are linked to the outside world
up here
in vermont okay thanks for the call
governor cuna won't you start
well the caller is right in that uh
link to the outside world up here
in vermont okay thanks for the call
governor cunha won't you start
well the caller is right in that
being a rural state we're very dependent
on this kind of interconnection and
telecommunications but i i believe that
the kind of action that you're calling
being a rural state were very dependent
on this kind of uh interconnection and
telecommunications but i i believe that
the kind of action that you're calling
for uh will have to be determined at the
at the federal level on the state level
i have formed a telecommunications
commission that for
uh will have to be determined at the at
the federal level on the state level
i have formed a telecommunications
commission that
is
including all of the actors involved in
order to make sure that for the future
vermont has the kind of
telecommunication linkages that is
including all of the actors involved in
order to make sure that for the future
uh vermont has the kind of
telecommunication linkages that keep it
uh
contemporary i mean these are the
highways
of our times and we will be making
proposals in that regard to keep it
contemporary i mean these are the
highways
of our times and we will be making
proposals in that regard to strengthen
our telecommunications system as far as
the individual satellites i'd be happy
to get more information on exactly what
you would recommend in that regard and
work strength in our telecommunications
system as far as the individual
satellites i'd be happy to get more
information on exactly what you would
recommend in that regard and work with a
congressional delegation to see that
that happens mayor sanders
i always think i have an answer to a
question i think i don't have a good
answer to this question
i just don't with a congressional
delegation to see that that happens
mayor sanders
i always think i have an answer to a
question i think i don't have a good
answer to this question
i just don't know all that much about it
but i would say this
television is an extraordinarily
powerful medium and one of the very
serious problems that exist in this
country tell all that much about it but
i would say this
television is an extraordinarily
powerful medium and one of the very
serious problems that exists in this
country today is that you have major
networks owned by very very wealthy
people who fill the airways with junk
and commercials and in fact as a result
of that people very often don't have a
is that you have major networks owned by
very very wealthy people who fill the
airways with junk and commercials and in
fact as a result of that people very
often don't have an understanding of
what's happening in their society one of
the
things that we did in burlington that
i'm very proud of is we had a cable
television system in brilliant that was
an understanding of what's happening in
their society
one of the
things that we did in burlington that
i'm very proud of is we had a cable
television system in berlin that was
inadequate that was not relating well to
the consumers and we said to them you
know what we're going to take it over
the city of burlington is going to have
a municipal system well it turned out we
didn't have to go that way because we
found inadequate that was not relating
well to the consumers and we said to
them you know what we're going to take
it over the city of burlington is going
to have a municipal system well it
turned out we didn't have to go that way
because we found and you mentioned the
name of that system green mountain cable
came into burlington and we now have a
very fine public access
system in burlington we now have an
expanded and you mentioned the name of
that system green mountain cable uh came
into burlington and we now have a very
fine public access system in burlington
we now have an expanded system which
allows the people in burlington to watch
this program today and a year ago they
would not have been allowed to do it i
am very excited about the idea of
opening up the airwaves to the pete
system which allows the people in
burlington to watch this program today
and a year ago they would not have been
allowed to do it i am very excited about
the idea of opening up the airwaves to
the people to allowing good discussions
to take place allow local programming
tonight in burlington the board of
aldermen meeting is being televised so i
think opening up the airwaves to the
people angle to allow in good
discussions to take place allow local
programming tonight in burlington the
board of aldermen meeting is being
televised so i think opening up the
airwaves to the people allowing people
to get on the airways to communicate
with each other is an extremely
important development which i support
lieutenant governor smith
i gotta make two comments first of all
go people to get on the airways to
communicate with each other is an
extremely important development which i
support lieutenant governor smith
i've got to make two comments first of
all going back to the last question it
wasn't anthony polina and it wasn't
governor cunanan it was francis horrigan
who's a democrat and a state senator and
a farmer from franklin back to the last
question it wasn't anthony polina and it
wasn't governor cunanan it was francis
horrigan who's a democrat and a state
senator and a farmer from franklin
county and if it wasn't for him there
wouldn't have been any bill last year
that's the man who deserves the credit
now in terms of your question about
dishes i'm with the mayor and i suspect
from county and if it wasn't for him
there wouldn't have been any bill last
year that's the man who deserves the
credit now in terms of your question
about dishes i'm with the mayor and i
suspect we're both with the governor we
don't quite know enough about what your
question is to answer it substantively i
will within three to four weeks be
publishing a stud we're both with the
governor we don't quite know enough
about what your question is to answer it
substantively i will within three to
four weeks be publishing a study on
technology precisely based on the idea
that as we're the railroads and as where
the interstates in this state went
and be on technology precisely based on
the idea that as we're the railroads and
as where the interstates in this state
went
and you have the examples of history
where in fact we have the electronic
highways that's where affluence that's
where jobs that's where good education
is going to go in any county have the
examples of history where in fact we
have the electronic highways that's
where affluence that's where jobs that's
where good education is going to go and
any county any town any child any school
that's off those electronic highways is
going to be getting a second rate shot
so we're going to have a study we've
been raised any town any child any
school that's off those electronic
highways is going to be getting a second
rate shot so we're going to have a study
we've been raised 50 000 from the
private sector we've had a team of
experts traveling to other states we're
going to have a comprehensive proposal
and it isn't going to be publicly funded
it's going to be fifty thousand dollars
from the private sector we've had a team
of experts traveling to other states
we're going to have a comprehensive
proposal and it isn't going to be
publicly funded it's going to be a very
innovative one but the goal is to make
sure that people aren't deprived the
opportunities of the age that is with us
whether they're satellite owners a very
innovative one but the goal is to make
sure that people aren't deprived the
opportunities of the age that is with us
whether they're satellite owners or
whether they in fact need a fiber optic
wire over the long haul those people are
going to be able to tap in that's going
to be good economic news good cultural
news good sit or whether they in fact
need a fiber optic wire over the long
haul those people are going to be able
to tap in that's going to be good
economic news good cultural news good
civic news for every man woman and child
in this west palm beach florida you're
on the air go ahead please
yeah i wanted to
ask this question to mayor news for
every man woman and child in this west
palm beach florida you're on the air go
ahead please
yeah i wanted to
ask this question to mayor sanders i
wanted to ask him
stepping back from the campaign a little
bit and looking at the other two
candidates objectively uh sanders i
wanted to ask him
stepping back from the campaign a little
bit and looking at the other two
candidates objectively uh doesn't he
think that his candidacy is directly
hurting madeleine cunanan
and that people who vote for him would
normally be
doesn't he think that
his candidacy is directly hurting
madeleine cunanan
and that people who vote for him would
normally be her supporters
and
the
doesn't he see her as a lesser of the
two evils and how would he feel about
contributing to her demise supporters
and
the
doesn't he see her as a lesser of the
two evils and how would he feel about
contributing to her demise
governor how does it feel to be the
lesser of two evils i think that's
really what this campaign is about
what we have done in burlington for a
month is of national significance
governor how does it feel to be the
lesser of two evils i think that's
really what this campaign is about
what we have done in burlington for a
month is of national significance and
that's exactly what i want to see happen
in the state of vermont what we have
done is brought together a coalition of
working people
and elderly people and individuals and
that's exactly what i want to see happen
in the state of vermont what we have
done is brought together a coalition of
working people
and elderly people and independent
independent-minded people who had the
courage who had the courage to break
with a democratic and republican party
as a result of that fact we have climbed
independent-minded people who had the
courage who had the courage to break
with a democratic and republican party
as a result of that fact we have come
close to doubling the number of people
who vote in burlington elections we have
far more people participating in the
civic life of our community we've
brought forth
so close to doubling the number of
people who vote in burlington elections
we have far more people participating in
the civic life of our community we've
brought forth
significant breakthroughs in tax reform
housing women's rights youth programs
cultural activities etc etc what has got
to happen here in the state of vermont
significant breakthroughs in tax reform
housing women's rights youth programs
cultural activities etc etc what has got
to happen here in the state of vermont
and this is my dream and i'm very
maybe i feel this very strongly
is i am concerned about what's going on
in this country i am concerned about and
this is my dream and i'm very
maybe i feel this very strongly
is i am concerned about what's going on
in this country i am concerned about the
fact that essentially deep down the
democratic and republican parties are
essentially alike that on the national
level that on the state level basically
neither of the fact that essentially
deep down the democratic and republican
parties are essentially alike that on
the national level that on the state
level basically neither of those parties
are standing up representing working
people representing poor people making
the fight that has to be made against
the absurd national priorities today
that are leading us as parties are
standing up representing working people
representing poor people making the
fight that has to be made against the
absurd national priorities today that
are leading us to a nuclear war at the
same exact time we're cutting back on
programs for poor people for the elderly
in an education we need a revitalization
of politics in the state of vermont to a
nuclear war at the same exact time we're
cutting back on programs for poor people
for the elderly in an education we need
a revitalization of politics in the
state of vermont tomorrow there's a
primary election here in vermont for the
democratic and republican parties my
guess is that about 20 of the people who
are eligible to vote will come out and
vote people are disgusted tomorrow
there's a primary election here in
vermont for the democratic and
republican parties my guess is that
about 20 percent of the people who are
eligible to vote will come out and vote
people are disgusted with status quo
politics the answer is not whether
governor cunha is better or worse than
peter smith i've known both of them for
years i like both of them the honest
intelligent people the question with
status quo politics the answer is not
whether governor cunha is better or
worse than peter smith i've known both
of them for years i like both of them
the honest intelligent people the
question is is whether in the state of
vermont we're going to bring together
the environmentalists the vast majority
of our people the working people the
elderly people the farmers to begin to
stand together to fight for news is
whether in the state of vermont we're
going to bring together the
environmentalists the vast majority of
our people the working people the
elderly people the farmers to begin to
stand together to fight for a decent
life for all of our people it's not
going to be led by governor cunanan and
it is not going to be led by mr smith we
need to break from the two-party system
and i'm very excited that we are going
to do something in decent life for all
of our people it's not going to be led
by governor cunanan and it is not going
to be led by mr smith we need to break
from the two-party system and i'm very
excited that we are going to do
something in vermont we are going to do
something in vermont that has never been
done in our history and that is elect an
independent governor of the state of
vermont and we're going to do something
that has not been done in 50 years in
the united
that has never been st in our history
and that is elect an independent
governor of the state of vermont and
we're going to do something that has not
been done in 50 years in the united
states of america elect an independent
governor outside of the democratic and
republican parties who is a progressive
who is prepared to take on the
establishment and the big money
interested states of america elect an
independent governor outside of the
democratic and republican parties who is
the progressive who is prepared to take
on the establishment and the big money
interests sorry we have two minutes left
and i'll give a minute to the governor
and then i'll get a minute to the
lieutenant governor thank you i think we
have to really make one very strong
point here and that sorry we have two
minutes left and i'll give a minute to
the governor and then i'll get a minute
to the lieutenant governor thank you i
think we have to really make one very
strong point here and that is there is a
real distinction
between me as a democratic governor and
my republican opponent we have produced
results in what frankly isn't it is
there is a real distinction
between me as a democratic governor and
my republican opponent we have produced
results in what frankly is an
extraordinary period of time we have
brought a new vitality to this state in
a way that perhaps the mayor doesn't
understand one is that we have involved
women extraordinary period of time we
have brought a new vitality to this
state in a way that perhaps the mayor
doesn't understand one is that we have
involved women in public life in a way
that they aren't involved in any other
state in the country and not simply
because they're women but because
they're outstanding people in my
administration we've in public life in a
way that they aren't involved in any
other state in the country and not
simply because they're women but because
they're outstanding people in my
administration we've retired the deficit
we've put vermont
again in the forefront as a strong and a
proud environmental state and that is a
major achievement and we've tired the
deficit we've put vermont again in the
forefront as a strong and a proud
environmental state and that is a major
achievement and we've been fiscally
responsible while we've been socially
humane and it's that kind of distinction
and i that i think distinguishes me from
my republican we've been fiscally
responsible while we've been socially
humane and it's that kind of distinction
and i that i think distinguishes me from
my republican opponent i'm not afraid
to retire the deficit and to spend money
where i think it counts in education and
making people independent 60 seconds
left opponent i'm not afraid
to retire the deficit and to spend money
where i think it counts in education and
making people independent 60 seconds
left i think it's fair to say that the
campaign has begun and i want to
congratulate the governor for being here
and i'm delighted that she's agreed to
27 other forums and debates because i
think it's fair to say that the campaign
has begun and i want to congratulate the
governor for being here and i'm
delighted that she's agreed to 27 other
forums and debates because this is
exactly the kind of stuff we're going to
be talking about now i have to tell you
caller from west palm beach i'm going to
have to tell you that i don't think
bernie sanders helps the governor i
think this is exactly the kind of stuff
we're going to be talking about now i
have to tell you call caller from west
palm beach
i'm going to have to tell you that i
don't think bernie sanders helps the
governor i think it hurts the governor i
think bernie sanders hurts me honest god
all the smart people see it the other
way i happen to think he hurts me i
don't know what that will tell you and i
got to tell you something that hurts the
governor i think bernie sanders hurts me
honest god all the smart people see it
the other way i happen to think he hurts
me i don't know what that'll tell you
and i got to tell you something else
when you look at these three people
sitting in front of you tonight there's
only one of us who dedicated almost 10
years of his life to helping working
people in a hands-on way when you look
at these three people sitting in front
of you tonight there's only one of us
who dedicated almost 10 years of his
life to helping working people in a
hands-on way and that was peter smith
what did we do we started the community
college of vermont and today thousands
second largest college in the state of
vermont thousands of and that was peter
smith what did we do we started the
community college of vermont and today
thousands second largest college in the
state of vermont thousands of working
men and women can go to school as
part-time students and improve their
lives because i and a number of other
gifted men and many women
working men and women can go to school
as part-time students and improve their
lives because i and a number of other
gifted men and many women
put in the time and the sweat and took a
risk to create a college system that is
still today unique in the united states
of america i'm proud of it
put in the time and the sweat and took a
risk to create a college system that is
still today unique in the united states
of america lieutenant i'm proud of it
governor smith thank you very much i'd
like to thank mayor bernard sanders of
burlington very much over ready we just
began we've spent an hour and a half of
time believe it or not lieutenant
governor smith and also governor thank
you very much i'd like to thank mayor
bernard sanders of burlington very much
we just began we've spent an hour and a
half of time believe it or not
lieutenant governor smith and also
governor madeline cunanan if you've
enjoyed our programming from burling for
not burlington vermont from montpelier
excuse me very much
first thing you have to thank is super
madeline cunanan if you've enjoyed our
programming from burling from not
burlington vermont from montpelier
excuse me very much
person you have to thank is susan
bundock who set it all up and made all
the phone calls and put an awful lot of
work into it she did an excellent job
she deserves a great deal of credit also
in charge of master control and rosen
bundock who set it all up and made all
the phone calls and put an awful lot of
work into it and she did an excellent
job she deserves a great deal of credit
also in charge of master control and
director for all of our programs brett
betsel charge of the field cruise was
greg gursky and the chief engineer
richard fleeson they all did an
excellent job i'd like to thank them i'd
also like to thank the people of mecca
for all our programs brett betsel charge
of the field cruise was greg gursky and
the chief engineer richard fleeson they
all did an excellent job i'd like to
thank them i'd also like to thank the
people of montpelier for being so kind
to us if you've been watching us and
have been calling we appreciate it have
a nice evening
montpelier for being so kind to us if
you've been watching us and have been
calling we appreciate it have a nice
evening
[Music]
i'll play it
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
that spells vermont
[Music]
that spells
vermont paradise and holidays
[Music]
and
[Music]
on my holidays and holidays
[Music]
you